[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the podcast
we're back with another
ama roll on edition of the show
if you're new to this youtube channel
hit subscribe hit that little
notification bell so you can be alerted
we're putting out tons of great content
and i love seeing the youtube channel
the version of this podcast on youtube
grow and i appreciate everybody who's
taken that journey
with us i'm back with adam my man adam
skolnick hype man podcast hype man
yes journalist author adventurer
swim run aficionado co-author of david
goggins can't hurt me
that's the bio right yeah it's good i
always like it when you read it i love i
love it
i didn't read anything no i know it you
speak it
yeah um it's good to see you again
good to see you i've been enjoying this
i feel like we're finally hitting a
groove with this
trying to figure out how we want to
leverage this this
this type of podcast um and i think
we're
we're starting to narrow in on what it
is that we
want to do here which feels good agreed
it feels great it's good to have the
template
and it's fun to figure out what the what
where we decide to dive in it's always
interesting to like figure that out
especially this week which was there
wasn't this
you know the big news story this week um
was not kind of the same as last week so
we had to kind of figure out how to how
to approach things
yeah so the news cycle moves so quickly
that even two weeks ago when we put up a
show it was somewhat dated from the two
days that
lapsed in between recording it and
putting it up the cycle has slowed a
little bit but just
you know a little behind the scenes for
everybody who's watching or listening
adam and i put together an outline and
we kind of go back and forth over the
course of two weeks
and what was relevant seven days ago
we end up mixing that and and updating
it because the news moves so quickly
here and again this is not
a new show we're trying to laser in on
topical issues
that are somewhat evergreen but show up
in the news cycle
yeah but you know this was one of the
few times we were kind of ahead on what
was happening in portland and that's
kind of stayed as one of the biggest
stories that in the covid relapse so
right um so you know instead of boring
everyone on the same old topics uh we
don't go
there to this time right yeah so if
you're new to the show
uh we have a couple segments that we do
some opening remarks
a little bit from the news a little show
and tell
we take an advertiser break and then we
come back with listener questions
if you would like your question
considered
and read on air you can leave a
voicemail for us at 424-235-4600
or you can leave it on our facebook
group page but i'm liking these
voicemails they're great and i i have to
thank everybody who's called the calling
it's definitely
there's been an uptick in messages and
and so we're seeing that and i
appreciate everybody who's calling and
i'm going through every single one
listening to every single one
and slotting them in and if we don't get
to you today
um we still have you in the in the in
the uh
can and and uh we will get to them over
the course of the life of this uh
ama it's cool to listen to them i think
it takes a certain amount of courage and
vulnerability to you know leave your
voice and and your name and
you know i understand some people want
it to be anonymous and that's fine but
uh it's
it's it's cool and it makes me feel like
this is
a community which is the whole idea and
and really the impetus behind this
version of the podcast to try to
uh make it a more communitarian
inclusive
version of what i typically do when i
just interview
people yeah it's a chance to interact
and and to
and to get into topics you could you
can't you don't have time when you're
talking to a hoover
dr hooverman or someone like that you
know you're not going to talk to
him about stuff that's you know that
isn't relevant no
so uh this is a chance to be more
generalist as you like to say
to get into the into the range right of
what rituals all about
so we got good stuff for you guys today
i want to open it up with a little
update on our boy tommy rivs uh
we spoke about him was it two weeks ago
i think yes
um at that time tommy rizz for for
people that don't know
is a legendary ultra runner he's beloved
in the endurance community he's just a
beautiful
beautiful human being who is suffering
from some very
significant and dire health
health circumstances at the moment when
we last recorded this podcast
he was experiencing what was being
characterized at the time as quote
unquote covid-like symptoms some severe
respiratory
distress since we recorded that
in between the time in which we recorded
that and it went live he
went into a coma and then the family
got to work trying to figure out a way
to move him to a facility that could
properly diagnose him because he was
undiagnosed at that time
he got moved to a facility in scottsdale
from flagstaff where he was previously
and received a diagnosis which uh
is a very rare and aggressive
form of lymphoma called primary
pulmonary nkt
cell lymphoma i understand that he is
now
out of that coma but um very much
you know still in um a very serious
uh situation he's sedated according to
his brother jacob he's less inflamed his
oxygen levels are improving
so that's good news it feels like it's
moving in the right direction and i
understand that he's going to be
undergoing if he hasn't already
some cancer treatments and i don't know
the details of that but
thank you to everybody who reached out
who contributed to the gofundme campaign
i'm going to put a link to that again in
the show notes
they have raised over 433 thousand
dollars
which is incredible um tommy of course
because he's such a big-hearted
individual is asking
that uh that people also consider
donating to
clean water for the navajo nation
there's a link to that up in
the gofundme for tommy and his family as
well so i can link that up as well
and in addition um his brother and his
family organized a run with rivs
which is a um you know communitarian
kind of run to raise awareness and and
funds for tommy and his family
the idea is you pick a day between
august
1st and august 9th to run hike walk
whatever just move put some miles in
for rivs and they also just announced
an auction called the rajon auction
which
you can find on facebook and that's live
between
august 3rd and august 13th if you go to
facebook.com
rageonauction you can find more
information there
i'm going to donate a couple books for
that people are just bidding on
on stuff and that's another way to
support
him and his family amazing in the
meantime if you want to stay current
with his condition the best place to do
that is just following his brother jacob
on instagram jacob pusey p-u-z-e-y
and he's posting daily updates to keep
everyone apprised
of how he's doing and the run with ribs
is kind of like
as many miles as you want or whatever
you want i think it's it's like a social
media thing like you put some runs in
you post it you help raise awareness for
him and what he's going through so
heart goes out to tommy and his family
hell yeah it's going to be a longer
journey than even just covid
yeah yeah for sure for sure but i'm glad
he's been diagnosed and he's getting the
treatment
that he absolutely needs and deserves
meanwhile
on the subject of putting miles in you
just put in your first
10 mile swim run the other day
i did
in my climate change chic gear how'd
that go
i went well you know i had i had um
been having problems with my foot again
it was like the same foot that
i broke uh ages ago which
without realizing it and walked on it
for several months and then
became a chronic condition and slowly
was able to get back and
and first on a treadmill and then
finally running and but it's something i
have to manage it's like a pain thing
and so it had just come back
and i was and uh i was having trouble
but then i decided to give it a go
and um lace them up and and go out and
do a 10
i didn't think it was like 10 and a half
miles um
like running to swimming that's right a
little bit yes eight and a little bit
over two yeah two and a quarter swimming
i think
and around santa monica yeah so i run
from my place down to the beach and then
up um to the end of the bike path there
by bellar bay
and then swim down and then ran up a
multi so i did a full
rich roll running through the
neighborhood in my in my uh
gear and i definitely got some looks
this time
uh cyclists when cyclists totally decked
out and lycra are giving you looks about
how you look
then you know you know you're you're in
new territory
you gotta check it out yeah the the best
i found the best
swim run training that's most
appropriate
for the courses that you find in the
otillo races
yeah is in and around the the bluffs of
point doom
like that original swim that you took me
on around the point
and then going up those trails i don't
know if those tr they may be closed
right now i don't know well no they're
open i mean that's where i trained for
catalina when i was doing that but
um it's just such a haul for me to get
out to point doom and back
um if not even if i'm just diving the
reef like i do
um it's like four and a half to five
hours and um it's just
impossible but from this what i love
about this is it gets me in the ocean
without having to do that i'm like
literally it's it's two hours two like
normally if i just do a seven mile or
six miler one
it's like under an hour and a half and
it's right from my door and so it just
feels like
what this sport's supposed to be about
like you leave from your door right and
you're back like
that's the beauty of living in santa
monica so for a long time i was avoiding
the bay
because i love doom and i love how clear
it is and the water's clean
and it's an mpa and i still love doom
but that's now
really mostly a dive site for me and if
i'm doing swim workouts it's in the bay
and it's cleaner than i thought i've
seen white sea bass there there was a i
mean there was a
14 foot shark sighting off sunset point
wasn't
far from there wow i didn't hear about
that yeah yeah yeah um
so it's it's wild out there too to a
lesser degree you get dolphins coming by
um but uh but yeah it's just
i do love it i am addicted to it i feel
so much better than just if i run
eight straight like just doing that like
a different thing
switching gears really puts it over the
top it gives
i feel like it's a better workout like
the full body
workout yeah and you never like when
you're doing it
i mean you did longer segments but when
you're doing these shorter segments
you're never comfortable like once you
settle into a rhythm then you gotta
switch it up again and your heart rate's
bouncing all over the place
that too and that's a huge difference
from triathlon or cycling where you're
kind of
in a certain groove and you kind of hold
it for a long time
yeah but now i'm i'm ready i could do a
15k could do like the the 15
now which is like what i wanted to prove
to myself and i mean i could see if you
just
if you have enough water and food you
could just keep going
it's like even three mile runs i mean
even multiples of them they're not that
they're not that hard so yeah yeah when
it when it was
when i was training for the world
championship version of that race
at its peak i was doing my i should have
been training much more in the ocean
than i was i was doing it in a pool but
it would be in and out and in and out
like
you know like for like hours and hours
different yeah
and like and then i think the world
championship has a 12 mile run in there
somewhere
yeah late like like two-thirds or three
or three quarters into it yeah
well i was grateful for that because i
just wanted to get into a rhythm
uh yeah you know all the switching gears
was much more challenging for me
than just the plane running but correct
me if i'm wrong
you're just kind of winging this right
it's not like you're working with a
coach or
you've got a plan or a program you're
just like i think i'll do this today
well our friend ted mcdonald helped me
get ready for catalina
shout out to ted yeah shout out to ted
and and and that was really helpful but
basically what happened is quarantine
happened and
uh i don't really go anywhere i go to
the farmers market once a week i come
here
every two weeks and other than that i'll
i'll either drive to point doom for a
dive or i'm swimming and running right
and mostly it was running at first
because the
the trails were closed and the beaches
were closed and so i started doing these
double-digit runs for the first time
and uh which was great and so then when
the
is opened and we can get back out there
i started to kind of
switch it up and i still was doing one
run uh a week
but it was really just you know the gyms
were closed everything was closed so i
just started winging it
and um and you know seeing if my foot
could hold up and it's mostly has right
yeah
well i think that's a good place to talk
a little bit more
generally and broadly about training
principles
we can have a segment oh training
because as as as proud as i am
of what you've been doing i think that
you would benefit from
having a little bit of a program or is
this an intervention right
a little bit what am i doing here i
don't want to rain on your parade or
anything like that
but in my experience when you're just
out like waking up in the morning and
saying oh i think i'll do this today and
spontaneously going out like that's
great and i think you'll
first of all the most important thing is
that you love what you're doing and
you're enjoying it because that
will you know basically give you the the
the impetus and the
level of emotional engagement to keep
going so i'm not
dissuading you from that in any way
whatsoever but i do think there's wisdom
in having a little bit of a plan and
intentionality
about what you're doing in my experience
when people are just haphazardly going
out and doing whatever
you can reach a certain level of fitness
and competence but you will
inevitably reach a plateau and most
people
just are never able to break through
that plateau to the next level
because they're not intentional in what
they're doing they're just going out and
winging it
and i think quarantine this stay in
place moment that we're all experiencing
you know along a spectrum because not
all of us
yeah exactly depending upon where you
live and
you know many other variables it is an
opportunity
to think about first principles here and
get back to basics and really
be mindful about what it is that you're
trying to do
trying to achieve trying to accomplish
and because there are no races on the
calendar
we can all rest easy and take a breath
and say
i don't have this thing on the calendar
right now so how can i make the most of
this
moment of repose and i think what i keep
coming back to
is the idea of not necessarily starting
over
but essentially building a proper
foundation
okay starting from the very beginning no
matter how fit you are saying okay
let's be a beginner here a perfect
example is
i see this all the time with swimmers in
iron man and triathlon
people who didn't grow up swimming and
don't necessarily
have the best technique and because
they're time crunched and because the
race is on the calendar and coming up in
a number of weeks or months
they feel so compelled to get in their
volume and their wattage you know
whatever
like making sure that they're fit but
they're overlooking
their technique so they're slapping
around in the pool right and
it's like no if you would just stop and
not worry about your fitness for a
minute and hone in on your technique and
spend a month
just focused on proper technique you
will have tremendous gains that will
allow you to break through
that plateau and reach the next level
and i think we have that opportunity
right now so
i would encourage anybody and everybody
who's fitness minded
to think about how to build a foundation
to focus on technique and
this is the moment to focus on
functional body strength things like
core
core strength and i was thinking whether
you're running or you're swimming or
you're on a bike or whatever
discipline it is that you're that you're
doing
being technic technique-minded in this
moment right now
i think will pay off in the long run
yeah sorry to interrupt but i was
thinking uh in functional body strength
and overall like doing the 10 miles i
was thinking god if i if i because i do
want to
try to get to the point where i can do
like the
not the world championship necessarily
but like the longer version of this
which is what
uh 40k 45k or something like that
right um and to do that it's not just
fueling yourself better but you do need
to have beyond just the ability
to run longer distance you still need to
build in your long distance run of the
week you still need to do all that
but you also need to still be i think
lifting weights and doing weight
training or some sort of like functional
body training 100 yeah and i can tell
you that when my core is strong and my
back is strong
that i'm a much better athlete and i'm
able to maintain that technique under
duress when you start to get tired
instead of turning into a wet noodle
when you're running you're able to
maintain your form
and that's gonna obviously manifest in
in better performances so
with your example of trying to prepare
yourself for a longer version
of this swim run the focus should be on
those anoint those things that are
really annoying and that you don't want
to do when you're time crunched
like the core body strength yeah and the
technique work and the drills and all
those sorts of things
and at the same time that building that
foundation
to create the ultimate aerobic engine
right the most
efficient aerobic engine that you can
and the way that you do that and i
learned this through my tutelage under
chris
health for many years right is to focus
on
zone two training so what does that mean
this is something that i talked about
extensively in finding ultra and i'll
recap it briefly here but
essentially the body has two energy
systems you have your aerobic system and
you have your anaerobic system your
aerobic system
which is the energy system that you use
when you're
exerting yourself at a moderate level
relies on oxygen and fat for fuel
you have enough fat in your body to
propel you
for you know umpteen hours you don't
have to worry about it
uh your anaerobic engine relies on
glucose and
essentially that's something that can
get burned out in
45 minutes right you know you have to be
constantly refueling yourself so
your anaerobic system is what kicks in
when you notch it up to that higher gear
and you start exerting yourself sprint
work tempo work
and the like endurance sports and
especially ultra endurance sports
rely on the efficiency of your aerobic
system and you build that very slowly
over time by spending
a tremendous amount or percentage of
your training time
in what we call zone two so there are
different zones for training
one through zone five zone one would be
anything from a walk to a brisk walk
zone two is the next level up think of
it as
conversational speed whether you're
riding a bike or you're running
it's the cadence with which you can
carry on a conversation with your buddy
and complete your training without
feeling
over exerted there are ways of
calculating specifically
what that zone two is for you
specifically through heart rate training
lactate testing
and the like and we don't need to go
down that rabbit hole now i talked about
this in finding ultra for running
for me specifically my zone two
is a heart rate in the range of 130 to
typically for cycling it's 120 to 130.
people read that in my book and then
just assumed that that's applicable to
everybody so then
i would get people tweeting me saying i
ran at a 140 heart rate i was like
that's great but i don't know if that's
your zone too that's my zone too
everybody's going to be a little bit
different and i've done lactate testing
to establish those zones
so what people will find even people who
are fit
and have been out running or cycling or
whatever haphazardly like yourself for a
considerable period of time and feel
like they're fit
they'll quickly realize once they really
understand what their zone two
is if you're wearing a heart rate
monitor which everybody should when
they're training
and or at least when you're endeavoring
to train intentionally
you will realize that it's not very hard
to
tip into z3 and and oh yeah cap your
heart rated zone
i mean according to my watch i'm living
in zone 4 humbling
yeah it's very humbling yeah and it
takes a very long time
and a certain different kind of
discipline we think of discipline as
like what gets you out of bed in the
morning and like the goggins-esque like
hit it hard all the time
but the discipline with building this
aerobic engine is the discipline to hold
back when you feel like you want to go
harder yeah
because you want to finish your workout
and feel like you got something out of
it or that you did something
when you're training in zone 2
oftentimes you're going to complete your
workout and go is that it
like i want to go harder so you have to
hold yourself back
when you're out on a trail and you hit
an incline oftentimes you have to walk
in order to cap that heart rate
until you develop the efficiency the
proficiency
and the aerobic capacity to be able to
handle those
inclines without going over your zone
two right it's a patient's game
it takes a lot of time what we have
right now is time so i think now
is the moment to invest in that and i
can tell you from personal experience
and many other people that i know in
this space
that this is the ultimate secret to
breaking through that plateau to the
next level because when you
have invested in that zone two
methodology of training and you've
applied it over
a long period of time and built your
volume up very slowly
you will find like in my own personal
experience when i first started training
for ultraman
when i would go out for a run i would
have to run like 10 minute pace 10
30 pace in order to not go over my zone
two threshold
but by the time i lined up for ultraman
i could run
730 pace at the same heart rate so it's
not about
going out and running fast it's becoming
so efficient
in these motions that they are less
taxing over time
and that's really what you're trying to
work on and what peop most people do the
mistake that most people make is
they spend the vast majority of their
training time in what we call the gray
zone
and the gray zone is sort of in between
your aerobic energy system and your
anaerobic energy system where
you are training too hard to really
effectively
develop your aerobic engine but not hard
enough
to develop the power and the speed that
anaerobic training avails you right so
it's
it's what happens when you go out and
you're just like i'm going to run for 45
minutes you know
three days a week and just go as hard as
i can sustain it for 45 minutes
most likely you're in the gray zone and
again you will develop a certain level
of fitness doing that
but you will quickly become stuck and
never be able to
improve and certainly not experience any
quantum improvements until
you are mindful of your training spend
most of that time in the slower
zone two and then pick your anaerobic
moments for threshold work
and tempo work a couple times a week but
most of the training you're going to be
doing is going to be in that zone 2
space and again it takes humility to do
it because
you know you got to be willing to let
people who
are who appear less fit than you pass
you on the road or on the trail
and and just say it's okay i've got a
plan and that's the difference between
exercising and training right the
mindfulness and the intentionality
that goes into it when you become
uh adept at zone 2 aerobic training what
you're doing is you're
you're you're increasing mitochondrial
density and those big muscles
um and you're developing this efficiency
and this aerobic capacity that
once you've honed it and it took me many
years to do this again it's a patient's
game
it's it's like a superpower but it
doesn't happen quickly it's not a hack
it's the opposite of a hack right it's
being willing to put in the time
right over and and have a long view of
of what performance gains mean
are you offering to coach me rich i'm
not a coach
i got a i got a coach for you you got
ted he probably knows about this stuff
he does he
he does um i mean i think the first time
i heard about this beside your book um
because i obviously read about in the
book but mark allen i think on your show
talked about he won iron right in this
way yeah that's how he beat dave scott
right he's
like completely revamping his training
exactly and
there were other things too like
visiting the shaman and and
and and becoming one with the island
getting rid of the hacks that was
truly his real secret i will tell you
that and i believe that
but we did talk at length about zone two
you should go back and and listen to
that interview if you didn't listen to
it the first time around
but he would say that you know in the in
the winter when he would
start training again for the following
year uh ironman world championships are
in october every year
that he would have to walk the hills and
this is the you know iron man world
champion and he'd be like yeah i gotta
walk these hills because i don't want my
heart rate going over whatever his
zone two threshold was so if mark allen
can walk a hill
you can too well yeah and i have done
that because i've been trying to keep
track as opposed to pace uh heart rate
on this garmin i have the descent which
i got because it's good for free diving
and and has all the
bells and whistles or you think but
obviously we're gonna get into that
later
on how accurate it is um and i don't
wear
a heart rate monitor but i have tried to
um hold back at times but obviously at
times i don't
um and i have gotten a little bit
quicker but obviously i'm not doing
i'm mostly living in orange like which i
guess zone four
on almost yeah that's not good and
that's not good no
so um i have to go slower right
so we'll work on that and to reiterate
it's not about the gear we're gonna do
a show and tell segment where we're
going to talk about gear
because so many people want to know
about the gear
yeah but my refrain is always it's not
gear is helpful it's fun um but
when it becomes an impediment to you
just going out and doing like what you
did
yesterday yeah um then it's a problem
but we'll we'll get to that
in a later section all right cool i um
i'm excited about it i mean i am i i
totally see how
i can do 10 and it's not like i got off
the couch to do it i mean i've been
building up to it i've done some
you know 11 mile runs i've done seven
mile swim runs i mean i've been building
up to it so it's not like i
i wouldn't encourage people to get off
the couch to do it but i could see
how the difference between 10 and 20 is
like
it's it's the difference between 5 and
10 is nothing compared to the difference
between 10 to 20.
there's a reason why everyone falls
apart at mile 18 on the marathon yeah
because that's the difference between
somebody who has
truly um honed their
aerobic engine versus somebody who's
spending all their time like if you're
if you're a gray zone trainer then
you're going to fall apart at mile 18
yeah pretty much every time you see it
time and time again
so shout out to all my homies in the
gray zone
like yourself like you're definitely
like me i
haven't i haven't that could be the
title of this podcast don't live in the
gray zone i may have a smart watch but
i'm not a smart
uh swim runner right so that's that's
the thing about the gear the gear are
tools but if you're not using those
tools effectively and properly what use
are they okay i'm suitably shamed i'm
going to
buckle down right all right well let's
put a pin in that for now
all right pivot to teachable moment i'm
open to all uh
advices so yes my mitochondria need it
this is a segment we call teachable
moment what are we gonna learn today
adam
well you know i kind of i i teased this
a little bit but said we're not going to
get into it we're not going to get into
the weeds
of um portland but i wanted to get into
this like what the f
is dhs doing the department of homeland
security what are they doing
and basically what i've been thinking
about watching portland go down is
um we have this department called
department of homeland security which
uh just really to recap it very briefly
came
came about after 9 11. the idea was it
was this overarching government
federal agency that could more
efficiently exchange information with
local law enforcement
so we don't have a repeat of the
failures that allowed
people to train to bomb the you know to
fly planes into the towers
um that was the intent behind it there
was always this
the dissenters were always a little bit
worried about giving the government that
that kind of power for federal agencies
to be kind of interacting with local law
enforcement
and the scope is dictated by the patriot
act yes
the patriarch created the agency as far
as i remember and so
in this also tsa is part of the
department of homeland security
uh border patrol customs ice they all
fall under dhs
and so uh but if you just say that you
believe in the idea that there's this
agency out there to protect
the people that live in the united
states to give us safety and security
well to me like what's the point of
having a dhs
if you can't help contain a virus right
and so cut to last fall and early winter
the virus is is has gotten out from
wuhan it's all over the place italy is
having its problems
um and we don't do anything like people
are getting off planes from europe
and they are yeah from china yes there
was some containment people were brought
to military bases and quarantined for a
period of time but not not from europe
um right people were just like walking
off flights from italy
we all saw that viral video of people
backed up in chicago when they finally
decided they were going to try to test
and it just became this like petri dish
march 15th they they decided to in about
half dozen or no a dozen or more
airports
o'hare was the big one that we saw the
video of and it became like a two
three hour line which is the exact wrong
thing to do
under the auspices of okay we're now
going to start to manage this thing
and then start contrast interrupt but in
stark contrast to
some of the videos that i saw i'm sure
you did too of
airports in seoul and in beijing where
they had their testing completely dialed
in and there were no lines
exactly and so we have this this is the
backdrop the reason i'm bringing it up
is
here's this agency that's supposed to
protect us keep us safe keep us secure
drops the balls so poor they did such a
poor job
of managing corona and yet they're
putting their personnel
border patrol tactical teams bortak is
what they're called
in portland oregon same people also were
deployed to standing rock
by the way also deployed to portland to
deal with these
protests that have been ongoing since
george floyd was killed
and just recently i just saw over last
week
because of my reporting in the sonoran
desert because my reporting on the
border wall
i was in contact with an organization
called no more deaths
who drop water off for migrants as they
come across the border
and they also have humanitarian aid
stations set up
so if if people are suffering from heat
related or cold related whatever it is
there's there's places they can go for
water to be checked out by emts that are
volunteers all volunteer run
and the border patrol hates no more
deaths because normal death reports
on over you know abuses of of migrants
and
arrests and that can't a camp in eravaca
arizona a tented camp was raided
by uh 20-plus vehicles a chopper um
this is on friday they were just raided
at gunpoint
under what stated purpose there was a
warrant to
uh collect basically they were susp
the no more deaths believes that border
patrol
is thinking they're a smuggling
operation they had they had a warrant
for financial records
they took everyone's phones all their
computers but
in actuality what happened is tents were
slashed
30 plus migrants were rounded up
the volunteers were zip tied and and
held cuffed with zip ties for two hours
uh and you know medic medicines were
overturned beds were overturned the
place was trashed
uh cell phones that were being used to
to
photograph it and v and and log it were
confiscated
um volunteers won't get their uh their
cell phones back for a couple of hours
um the p the judge that signed the
warrant had signed one previously on no
more deaths so there's
there's this and and no more deaths
thinks they had just released a report
about the border patrol that that
implicates the border patrol union
in these raids on no more deaths and
they think it was payback
but who knows i mean because i haven't
reported the story out so i have not
gone to border patrol so i should say
that
right right away i'm getting this
straight from no more deaths but
knowing what no more deaths does having
researched them extensively
they are not a migrant smuggling
operation they are humanitarian
aid agency they're a non-profit um
and that's what they do so the point is
what is going on
with dhs why do we have a guy who's
running dhs getting into feuds with
governors
like what is going on yeah yeah yeah the
the
the fumbling of the covid response in
stark contrast to the
the the sort of authoritarian overreach
of this organization in places like
portland
raises a broader issue about power in
general
federal power versus state power and how
we're allocating
our governmental resources for the
behest of the people
yeah by definition the dhs is
to protect homeland security yes the
biggest threat to that at the moment
is this virus that shut down our economy
and is forcing us to
not interact with each other and is
creating tremendous havoc that will have
a ripple effect for
who knows how long to come and yet we've
been
incapable in getting a grip on how to
manage this
we're still seeing these crazy spikes
the united states is
spiraling out of control with respect to
new cases etc
meanwhile we've dispatched this
you know basically paramilitary
organization
to places like portland and the
the the argument being that there it's
an effort to protect
federal property right which is a small
portion of what's actually transpiring
in these places
and this organization has gone on to
you know rather than i mean the whole
it's a misuse of government systems this
this was all meant to
you know basically uh combat terrorism
essentially and under the
under the broad um authority of the
patriot act
it's allowed overreach so now we're
seeing
um these lists being made about
journalists
uh names being you know put on a ledger
yeah dossiers on journalists they're
baseball cards being made of arrested
protesters
which all feels very orwellian and
dystopian
and concerning irrespective of whatever
your political perspective
is this should give one pause and and
the guy who is
integral in creating like tracking those
two journalists that were in the
washington post story which i think
you're gonna link to
um the that guy was reassigned but he
wasn't fired
i mean so so what is happening you know
like and why
uh that's the that's the question here
you know like what should we be asking
of our government agencies and and why
and uh so that's the teachable moment
what's your what's your take on that
well my take is that uh everything's
upside down obviously
under this current administration but um
you know you have an environmental
protection agency that is cutting
environmental laws
um i don't know my takeaway on this is
that i'd
i'd like to hold this agency accountable
this agency to me is dangerous
it's dangerous to the civil liberties of
everyone who lives here
and we should be watching it and um you
know i don't have
a petition to give you i don't have
anything else but i would just like
listeners to pay attention to what is
happening at the department of homeland
security right now
and and and be very skeptical uh
to the point not to where you don't
believe everything but that you're
really paying attention to the
statements being made by chad wolfe
and by everything that comes out of the
dhs yeah
what's interesting also is that a core
principle of republicanism is states
rights
yes and here we have an overriding of of
state mandates for the purposes of a
federal flex
and that but that's been since trump
became president it's kind of cut both
ways whereas the you know democrats were
always for a big federal
kind of uh policy and now it really it's
states that are fighting for like
democratic principles like cal state of
california
so that's kind of cut both ways it just
so happens that that's the way it was
but it didn't happen that way under the
bush administration so it's interesting
how that all
has transpired but yeah so i just wanted
to flag that for the listeners because i
know listeners
are super concerned uh about
you know how to be better people and how
can we be a better country
and uh it doesn't seem like safety and
security
are right now uh the mandate of the dhs
it's a control
thing it's so strange yeah yeah
i mean department of homeland security
do you feel more secure
and it's also bizarre how how we um
kind of haphazardly normalize things
depending upon our political perspective
yeah that's true
you know what do you think about that
well i think it's
it's concerning it speaks to our our
cognitive biases
you know if you're of a certain
political persuasion you're going to
have a lens on what the dhs is doing
that's going to differ
from somebody who's on the other side of
the aisle yeah when in truth these
things should not be
partisan but we're not even talking
about like the protests
in portland like i'm not there i'm not
watching it every day it's not
it's you know i read about it from time
to time and your sense of what's
transpiring there if you're not there
depends wholly upon your information
silo it does
but like no matter what's happening
there
like we have to have we have to expect
the dhs to be an impartial partial
arbiter of
uh the constitution and and and how
that's laid out and so
and it doesn't seem like that's the case
when you're when you're enforcing uh
when you're cracking down on a
humanitarian aid organization in the
middle of [ __ ] desert
and you're cracking down on protesters
it seems like it needs to be either
disbanded because it's a failure
or overhauled completely to include some
you know the cdc or some sort of like
offshoot or
or corridor that links the cdc with the
dhs
yeah yeah yeah yeah it doesn't seem
super wise that dhs is
vested with authority of of
you know maintaining or trying to
establish some kind of security around
the spread of covid yeah when its real
mandate has to
you know emanates from 911 and terrorism
right
and and i'd like to point out that the
failure with containing kovid wasn't
just
international borders it wasn't just
customs tsa should have been
like taking everyone's temperature on
every single domestic flight in this
country
um that wasn't happening so maybe now it
is but it wasn't then
all right let's shift gears here let's
do it we're going to talk about a couple
letters
yes aren't we we are so this is
um this news came out i forget what it
was was it like three weeks ago four
weeks ago was it like four weeks ago i
think we talked about it
right when it first well no we talked
about it right before it dropped
yes it dropped about four weeks ago we
were talking about a little bit about
cancer culture and redempt and the
notion of redemption and um and then
like literally the next day the harpers
letter dropped and so this is a letter
that was spearheaded by a journalist
named uh thomas chatterton williams
and george packer and a few others and
it was signed
by legends really uh margaret atwood
gloria steinem wynton marsalis
uh malcolm gladwell salman rushdie gnome
chomsky
most of whom or all of whom are liberal
right liberal-minded uh there's i think
a hundred there were
there was a bunch of conservatives too i
mean the whole point was that it crossed
that aisle
and it was a it was a panoply of
perspectives and the idea was it was
kind of speaking out against
illiberalism illiberalism not being a
political statement but like on the idea
of free flow of ideas
liberal ideas like free speech and free
expression
uh and so i'll just read a little
excerpt here for you
um and uh and then we can discuss
kind of what we think of it uh the
excerpt is this the free exchange of
information ideas
the lifeblood of a liberal society is
daily becoming more constricted
while we have come to expect this on the
radical right sensoriousness
is also spreading more widely in our
culture an intolerance of opposing views
a vogue for public shaming and ostracism
and the tendency to dissolve complex
policy issues and a blinding moral
certainty
we uphold the value of robust and even
caustic counter speech from all quarters
but it is now all too common to hear
calls for swift and severe retribution
in response to perceived transgressions
of speech and thought
um it goes on um but
you know and it's in response to people
losing their jobs uh
losing their positions not based on
something like me too
but based on uh action like speaking the
wrong thing
saying they're making the wrong move a
guy was removed from a position in
harvard
for actually being the lawyer for harvey
weinstein that was his big offense he
represented harvey weinstein
like these are uh illiberal
dangerous forces my original knee-jerk
reaction
when this broke the news was it like two
and a half weeks ago or something like
that
um was that this is a conversation that
we need to have
and very rapidly there was a there was a
a reaction to this a counter reaction to
this letter
that was pretty severe yeah it came out
right aw
right away there was the the people who
i guess
the letter was targeting didn't take it
too well um and people were being
accused of
uh the the signees were being accused of
being elitist
and a lot of them are very accomplished
in elite people
um but there was a there's one of the
poets that signed it
um was a black poet who was an
ex-prisoner like he's an ex-con
so it's not like everyone's this elitist
yeah uh but
here but i think hannah uh i hope i'm
not butchering her last name
uh gorgeous uh from the atlantic
probably had the best rebuttal and
it explained itself the best i and and
so i'm gonna
read a little bit of it right now across
the globe the challenge facing
journalists and intellectuals is not the
pain of twitter scorn
the community to protect journalists
estimates that at least 250 journalists
were imprisoned worldwide last year for
their reporting
in the u.s the trump administration
continues to threaten reporters safety
and undermine the belief that
journalists play a valuable role in
democracy
the country is moving deeper into an
economic recession decimating industries
including journalism and academia
and yet the suddenly unemployed people
the harper statement references clearly
lost their jobs
not because of a pandemic or government
pressure but for actions criticized as
potentially harming marginalized groups
this small group includes james bennett
the former editor of the new york times
editorial page
who was forced to resign after the op-ed
page he was supervised published an
article by arkansas senator tom cotton
that endorsed state violence
and she was basically saying what that
like uh
these elitists are complaining about
being criticized not
right not complaining about something
that's real right the criticism was
was essentially that these are a bunch
of whiny elitists
who who now for the first time are being
forced to confront
criticism of their writing because none
of them are actually in jeopardy of of
being de-platformed or
losing their ability to express
themselves they all have massive
platforms and they're all going to be
just fine
but the broader truth here and where the
conversation really needs to center
is on this trend towards illiberalism
and the sensoriousness that is at play
across social media in a sort of
orwellian sense not that
the government is cracking down in any
kind of authoritarian way but that there
is this
social media kind of mob at large that
self-polices
what's acceptable speech and what isn't
you know i'm no fan of tom cotton but i
don't think that the editor of
the new york times editorial page should
have been fired for publishing
that letter certainly not because of the
content
of the letter i think he resigned under
pressure
i'm not exactly sure i think it was like
resigned
i think so but it was under pressure and
i think that the reason
that they gave is that he he didn't read
tom cotton's uh piece before it went to
print
um that's a different issue however uh
brett stevens who's another favorite
punching bag of left wingers and at the
new york times wrote a really convincing
op-ed about that and he said you want
people like tom cotton to tell you what
they're thinking
and what you don't want is to make tom
cotton
somehow a sympathetic figure to people
who care about free speech
because this guy is advocating for state
violence and like advocating basically
what we just were
flagging for people yeah and uh and
he's not for civil liberties clearly and
now he's the darling of people who you
know he was able to be set up as this
conservative
um avatar for like uh being abused by
this so
you know uh a biased media
you're basically showing the world that
you have a bias
um and that's not and obviously i don't
think new york times does have a bias
but that's what you're
that's the perception that could come up
right and so it's dangerous
i mean like the one thing that uh i
think
that um gorgeous didn't get right
is that these overreaches by the left
can lead to
a more hostility toward journalists
exactly for that reason
because you're overreaching and then it
becomes more convincing when someone
says fake news
it becomes more convincing look they are
certainly a danger i mean this is
something that that bill maher talked
about in his episode
this past week he interviewed um
chatterton williams and
and barry weiss as well who we're going
to get to and he pointed out
this study um i don't know the origin of
the study the cato institute i think
where 62 of people were afraid to share
their honest opinion
and i think that they're that's worth
exploring
because i just know personally in my
circle of friends
and journalists and writers that there
is
this what chatterton williams calls this
onlooker effect that it's not about the
criticism
that cancellation is not about bringing
the elites down to earth but it's about
this chilling effect this stifling this
narrowing influence on all of our
behavior
where we have to pause and consider
whether we really want to share what's
on our mind
and just the fact that you're going
through that calculus at all
i think speaks to the current
health or lack of health in public
discourse at the moment which should be
concerning to everybody
i i think so i mean um right after the
letter came out
i tweeted it and retweeted it and and
agreed
my own agreement i mean listen
principally
when i tweet it's like a lonely man on
the alpine lakes uh skipping a rock
like that's the kind of effect it has on
the greater world i'm not a title wave
maker like you rich role
but i'm not that on twitter i can tell
you that but uh
so no one really pays attention but even
that you know like
as soon as the backlash started to roll
out even i was and
and i'm very progressive i mean you're a
progressive contributor to the new york
times yes and i
and i and i have put myself in harm's
way to
report stories that uh that i'm proud of
that are human rights stories and
they're
but um and i was i thought about
deleting my tweet
it's probably it's probably
automatically knowing you as well as i
know you it's problematic when somebody
who is
as progressive and liberal-minded as you
somebody who is so devoted to humans
right human rights causes and
the kinds of stories that you devote
your life to like going to the
you know going down to the the wall in
arizona and
trying to understand the you know
deleterious environmental impact of what
that construction project is all
like these are the you know you've
you've reported on gmos in hawaii
like these are these are very
liberal-minded
stories to pursue and and when somebody
of your ilk
is being um accused of not being liberal
or progressive
enough and being shamed for pointing out
that
we we need like the health of our
society depends upon the free exchange
of ideas
then it's problematic it is i to be
clear i
i wasn't ashamed because nobody really
pays attention to my twitter but um
you said you got a little better i was
worried about that i see
i was worried about about being you're
thinking about it i was the onlooker
you know i was concerned about it yeah i
stuck i kept it out there
um and and i didn't have a backlash
uh and i kept it out there and i
actually then uh tweeted at
williams and and and thanked him for the
letter and and so i
i'm because i believe in that i believe
in the idea that we should have
free speech you know like it's dave
chappelle is
is constantly complaining about he won't
play colleges most comics won't play
colleges anymore that was like a
lifeblood for comics
like playing the college circuit that's
what kept people out of bars all the
time
and and and they were making a lot of
money on that college circuit it's no
longer there they don't do it
and and i think this whole thing points
to this weird
uh co-mingling of academia and newsrooms
which wasn't the case like when a guy
like carl bernstein
who with woodward broke the watergate
story he was a cub reporter that came
out out of high school got a job at a
paper
you can't get a job at a paper as a cup
reporter in high schoo out of high
school anymore
it doesn't exist part of that is that we
don't have
local papers that are as robust as they
used to be that
that's harder so now you have academia
feeding feeding newsrooms that's
different than we ever have before
and um in some ways that can be good i'm
not saying it's all bad
but i'm just saying it like this
this idea is one that came out of
academia first this idea of the
proper way to speak and that there is
you know the the
close societies was first a problem on
campus before it was a problem in
newsrooms
yeah i think it started with student
bodies and then those
those students matriculate and go out
into the world and they begin to
populate the newsrooms
and they they slowly begin to uh
you know have their have their voices
being shared on social media
and and you know the result is is kind
of what we're seeing right now
yeah and then you want to get to barry
as well right yeah
yeah um she was a signatory on a letter
she resigned from the new york times in
her resignation letter
she claimed to be a target of
progressive forces within the newsroom
there
and this is what she wrote a new
consensus has emerged in the press but
perhaps especially at this paper
that truth isn't a process of collective
discovery but an orthodoxy
already known to an enlightened few
whose job is to re inform
everyone else um
and so that's what her taking right yeah
right this is an interesting
um situation it's related to the
harper's letter although it's
distinct and it's its own unique thing i
think independent of that
as somebody who who is a contributor to
the new york times you have a sense of
what the inner workings of that
newspaper
are like i do know other uh writers for
the new york times who
take issue with barry's characterization
of what that climate is like there
and i wouldn't i wouldn't you know
consider myself a big barry weiss stan
or fan
or anything like that i think she's done
some interesting reporting
i don't agree with everything that she
says um
but it does speak to
the chatterton williams letter in the
sense that there
is this feeling of orthodoxy
that supersedes fact-finding
or science or the pursuit of truth
yeah i think it's the same thing that
we're talking about dhs
i think overall and i wouldn't put it
just to the new york times i think
overall
it's it's more of an uh let's be aware
of what's really happening
my experience in new york times is
confined to the sports desk i've never
had
any issues it's always been like like
the best people that i i've ever worked
with in journalism
um so and i have no insight into how the
newsroom
operates um and
part of the criticism of barry though is
that is that this was like a press
release for her next move
whether it's right that's her creating
some new media platform or whatever it
is there's a little bit of grandstanding
oh for sure i mean she is she is but at
the same time it's like
this idea like i think the ideas
concerns me more than the way the new
york times operates fine
they're great um to me the the issue is
are we going to confront is is the left
kind of setting themselves up as this
new mccarthyist type era is there a
purity test
because we we've joked about purity
tests in the past and it is like
becoming true
like are there purity tests that people
are gonna have to pass in order to get
to a certain level um with it's deeply
concerning and bill maher pointed this
out he's like who are these perfect
people out there yes that are holding us
all to account
according to some impossible standard
and how deep
does that reach extend in terms of
you know what's what's required to
escape
this cancellation and and and
where are they in terms of like the
cancel culture
people who are so ready to cancel people
for saying the wrong thing
when anti-semitism is the issue uh you
know we had 17 000 people marching in
berlin
against uh covid restrictions but it was
like the people who are fo who who
created that protest were far-right
politicians there were neo-nazis
involved
uh there is a big fear in germany right
now that neo-nazis are deeply embedded
in all forms of government there
and certainly in police forces and in
the military um
here we had issues with like ice cube
speaking up desean jackson speaking up
um
nick cannon on his broadcast said some
pretty terrible things
uh about jews quoting farrakhan um
desean jackson thought he was quoting
hitler at one point and and
and some some people uh you know desean
jackson then is
is going to go to auschwitz he's been
counseled
um nick cannon has been canceled and
barry weiss actually
uh just shouted him out on twitter about
how great it is that he is
educating himself and welcoming well you
know basically being the model
of allowing for redemption right of
course nick cannon did read her book
that might have something to do with it
um well there has to be a path to
redemption and rehabilitation you know
if somebody missteps
and in this culture where people are
misstepping all the time
to just expect that they're going to go
away forever
is not you know it that's not an
enlightened
you know perspective to have like what
are we doing
if somebody look nobody's nobody's
perfect and
people are are you know in the world and
on social media
communicating and people are going to
say the wrong things and in those
instances and look there's a spectrum of
severity here that we're speaking about
there are some
horrible things that are happening in
some minor transgressions
but we have to we have to determine
the half-life on these cancellations
and how we're going to create a culture
in which it's conducive to people
learning and growing in real time in the
public sphere
it's it's it's the difference between
the i think the real
concern here um with the onlooker effect
is it creates it seeds apathy
not empathy and to communicate and to
exchange ideas
um and even to misstep like nick cannon
did
uh but now he's showing publicly
empathy and to have barry weiss who
feels like she got chased out of a
newsroom
and this is her core issue like this is
the main she wrote a book about this
right
about anti the rise of anti-semitism i
mean look i mean we've had we've had
uh shootings in synagogues we've had i
mean this is not a
small thing and even on the left i hear
it in the wellness community all the
time people who are suspicious of george
soros as he's like some
bengali which is this whole whole
anti-semitic trope that has
has revitalized um so it's not just
right-wing it's not just left-wing
it's all over the place um but
what what do we where do we want to
encourage people to be
do we want them to become spectators of
a big twitter fight
that causes that doesn't solve anything
or do we want to have
empathy for one another are we creating
apathy are we creating empathy
um i think that's what the letter is
getting to with this onlooker effect
is like is that that you know for
creating apathy but we're creating an
tip
antithesis yeah right versus empathy or
like this idea that you're a frozen
onlooker that you're not going to get in
the fight
because that's the because well that's
that's the true onlooker exactly
i think people are just opting out yeah
and they're just saying i'm just not
you know i'm i'm i'm not participating
not for me because it's too
fraught yeah and for me to express
myself
honestly is this minefield that i'm not
going to
subject myself to and that's the
stifling and the chilling effect
right for me it's just like that's why i
swim run without any sort
of intelligence because i just want to
get get out there
flail around for hours right no i think
that's right i mean i i
uh anything else you want to share on
that no i think we'll we'll close it
with that and we'll move on
to what are we moving on to
show-and-tell show-and-tell
hard pivot hard pivot hard pivot
we just watched uh weight of gold it's
the hard pivot to the weight of gold the
hbo dock
featuring apollo ono and michael phelps
is the narrator and lolo jones great
sprinter turned
bobsledder um and it explores the mental
health challenges that olympic athletes
often face
during training competing and then
obviously after the the torch is
extinguished
so this documentary just premiered on
hbo this past week
i saw the trailer getting circulated by
a bunch of the athletes
and thought this is this is like right
up my alley i want to know more about
this i reached out to apollo
ono i just did a podcast with him that's
going to go up in a couple weeks
but why not take a moment now to talk
about the movie i mean i think it's
it's great that michael and all of these
athletes
are are have created this project
that focuses on what i think is a very
important and overlooked issue which is
the mental health of
our elite athletes whether they're
professional or olympic the lens in this
documentary is
is is honed solely on the olympic
athletes and you could make the argument
like oh woe
is me like they're olympic athletes like
they're having a hard time
but the truth is that there isn't
you know sort of an existential crisis
that's created when
you're somebody who is at the height of
their powers and whether you stand atop
the podium
or you end up in 20th place matters
little
what does matter is that almost
overnight when you become a civilian in
the aftermath of that experience
you're left without any resources to
manage how to move forward with your
life
right when you're used to being
surrounded by tons of people
who support you who are there for you
who are all invested
in your success and every waking moment
of your life is devoted to this
very specific window of time in which
you're expected to perform at your best
when that moment lapses and is over
how do you then become a normal human
being
and a lot of these people have severe
you know mental issues trying to grapple
with that and i think
it's incumbent upon the organizing
committees of all of these
respective sports to create structures
and programs for these athletes to
better help them make that transition
you're seeing that in some of the
professional leagues now yeah i know
they do it with finances like you know
how to manage your money and all that
kind of stuff but um you know the mental
aspect of
high performance is you know only now
starting to get the weight that it
deserves
what i thought was interesting was a
good point made by one of the figure
skaters
um not sasha but the other one um i
forget
gracie gold yeah yeah yeah and she was
saying if i tore up my knee i'd have the
best surgeon
right in the world looking at it um but
i don't have any i didn't have anybody
and uh to look at my after my mental
health that i got recommendations of a
therapist but i didn't have them
like paid for and and on the payroll and
available to me
like on the spot yeah and i find that
interesting because you know obviously
sports psychology and sports
psychologists that's
been a booming field for a while but
it's always about performance
right that's surprising to me that the
support psychologist
um role hasn't spanned overall mental
health
i'm surprised by that well i think that
the resources are available and this is
a point that apollo made it's not that
they weren't there
and available if you reached out for
them but
you have to take into consideration that
these are people who
who are trained to never show weakness
right right and so the idea of being
vulnerable enough to say hey
you know i'm feeling not good like i
need help
is a stretch for a lot of these people
and so they end up
not availing themselves of what is
available interesting and i think that
makes it even more incumbent upon the
coaching staffs and the
you know people that are in these
people's entourages to pay closer
attention to how they're doing but
you know the movie's good i think that
it it you know if i had a criticism of
it i think it lives a little bit on the
surface
yeah it could have probed a little bit
more deeply
there's some great stories there that
weren't fully fleshed out yeah exactly
yeah yeah
exactly um and you know come on michael
phelps are you gonna come on the podcast
yeah why
can't why haven't why isn't michael
phelps i've tried this i've been trying
for years
to get michael on i've made many
overtures
i've never met michael phelps but i have
friends that are friends with him
i know coaches that have coached him um
i
emailed recently i emailed peter
carlisle his agent i just get no i get
no response
so we're just commando what are you
doing i come on michael i got a chair
on the mic buddy yeah i mean he looks
amazing in the in the film he looks like
he looks like he's ready to compete is
what he looks like he looks amazing he's
really
shouldered this mantle of being a mental
health advocate
in a meaningful way yeah and i think
it's super cool
and it's powerful and these are stories
that need to get told so
kudos to michael kudos to michael one
day he will
show up on this podcast and share with
us about it
michael if you're listening you don't
look like a retired athlete you don't
you look like an athlete in prime
condition right um
and if you're not going to be saying
he's maybe thinking about a comeback i
thought about it but like if you're not
gonna do that
i think you should try freediving
because i think michael phelps would be
an incredible
like you know it could be an interesting
way of going it's a much more
introspective kind of like
meditative sport it's a huge challenge
and there's never been an athlete like
michael that
did that crossover that's something
alexi molchanov one of the
the right now the number one ranked
freediver in the world that he has two
of the world records
um in depth uh he's wanted to see that
he's wanted to see
like someone else crossover from another
yeah because alexi was a national ranked
swimmer
in russia um when a nationally ranked
swimmer in russia and his mother was too
when he then he transitioned into
freediving and so he's an elite athlete
and so is william schubert so there are
elite athletes in the sport
but you don't get like the swim there's
no swimmer pipeline
right yeah right that would be an
interesting crossover i think it's much
more likely that he'll try to
make the pga than go into free diving
golf seems to be his thing is that right
yeah yeah well there's no ocean in
arizona
right a couple more things to uh
talk about really quickly before we get
into audience q a
i did want to mention that my buddy
datsy bausch uh who's been on the
podcast before
you guys know her you love her uh
olympic track cyclist she started an
organization called
switch for good which is this
incredible non-profit promoting
the benefits of a plant-based diet it's
really kind of an
anti-dairy
advocacy group and i was privileged to
tape some psas for switch for good
recently that were directed by louis
ahoyas who
many might know as the director of game
changers and the cove in racing
extinction he's an amazing
academy award-winning director and i got
to
uh spend the day with a bunch of
incredible plant-based athletes like
rebecca sony who's a six-time olympic
medalist she's been on the podcast as
well
dotsy of course george larocque from the
nhl derrick morgan from the nfl
heather mitz three-time olympic medalist
soccer player and a bunch of other
really cool people and those psas
aired uh on nbc during the today show
and i think people keep coming up to me
saying they've seen them so i think they
were on
nbc um subsequent to that too
yeah yeah that's cool yeah yeah so
that's really cool and uh
if you missed those you can find them on
the switch for good youtube channel and
i'll link that up in the show notes as
well so datsy's doing great work
it's basically a response to the
kind of got milk chocolate milk
campaign that the dairy industry um
promoted that's like which well what
happened is
in my estimation at least the dairy
industry
noticing um
shrinking demand for its products made
this
interesting decision to reposition
chocolate milk
not as like the drink that kids you know
elementary school kids drink at lunch
but as an athletic recovery supplement
of some sorts that would enhance your
recovery and they put a lot of money
behind this
a lot of money into advertising into
sponsoring athletes
and dotsy and her organization and a
bunch of
athletes like myself were like that's
it's not right
no no it's really not right so this is
sort of a response to that
to correct the record as much as
anything else so shout out to dotsy
well i mean i think athletes have are
have been playing a huge role in this uh
growing uh plant-based
movement movement away from animal
products i mean i don't think there's
any doubt
that performance and athletics and
mentors from the athlet from the sports
community
um has has been a big driver in that
don't you agree
yeah do you think chocolate milk is a is
it the ultimate recovery drink
no um i can't drink milk man
most people can't no i can't drink milk
i can't even
eat ice cream yeah i eat not nut milk
ice cream now
or oat milk that's the new one oatmeal
oatmeal the new thing i'm into oatmeal
yeah
it looks good yeah a couple other quick
things
uh my brother-in-law stewart mathis
julie's brother
stewart that's your brother-in-law i
forgot i forgot the link up
he's like he was great he is a brilliant
guitar player yeah and this is a guy who
who picked up a guitar when he was i
don't know eight or nine years old and
just never looked back like there was
there was nothing else that he was ever
gonna pursue in his life other than
music and the guitar and he
you know i wouldn't say suffered is the
wrong word but like he bled for his art
for
many many many years like living in la
in all different kinds of bands cutting
his own records
and it took a long time for him to
finally hit his groove
but now he's like lauded and
in the music community like most people
know who he is this is an incredible
guitar player and he's played
he was jules uh tour guitar player
he uh he toured with leanne rimes and
then he was in the wall flowers
oh really many years yeah and he's been
playing with lucinda williams for
right he's he he moved to nashville it
was in nashville now um but
the reason i'm bringing it up is that
lucinda and stuart just played an npr
tiny desk concerts
for those who aren't familiar npr does
this series called tiny desk
where these amazing musicians play these
intimate little contained concerts and
uh the one with stewart and lucinda just
published recently so i'll link that up
in the show
and you could see my brother-in-law
julie's brother
and you'll get why her side of the
family is so musically inclined
yeah which is cool yeah i like that
thanks for sharing that
um final thing there's a new documentary
that just came out called
take out by michael cewerski who
is documentary filmmaker who's made some
cool movies over the years food choices
um being one of them and this is a
documentary produced executive produced
by moby i have not watched it yet
he michael just sent me a link to check
it out so i'll i'm gonna watch it this
week but
it's another um sort of look at
the environmental impact of our food
choices through the lens of
how the amazon is being destroyed to
create uh fields for cattle grazing and
and growing crops for cattle
okay one of those uplifting docks yeah
the fires and the amazon
oh really yeah all right so that's it so
should we talk about some gear
let's talk about gear let's talk about
the gear that's going to change
show-and-tell i'm going to change my
game i got a couple you know i just want
the listeners to realize that i had no
idea
how much rich uh didn't approve of my
training habits
until i sat down i didn't say that i
didn't say that
i'm celebrating what you're doing i just
want to put a little structure
in it i'd love it man yeah i'd love it
yeah so uh
on the gear tip again my disclaimer is
that it's not about the gear you don't
need any of this gear to perform
and when people reach out to me and ask
me questions about what wash are you
wearing or what should i get
i essentially never respond because i
just don't even want to be
involved in that discussion because
again it's not about that and i feel
like
this is an example of analysis paralysis
where people get so caught up in
what watch they need or what pair of
shoes they need or what kind of bike
they should buy
that they never end up just going
outside and moving their bodies right
until they have this this sort of
equation completely figured out which of
course they never figure out
because the whole point is to protract
the process of being focused on the gear
yeah that being said because i'm asked
so often and so frequently about this
i'm going to take this moment to discuss
it and then
maybe never discuss it again maybe never
so the first thing is
um people on youtube have been leaving
comments like why are you wearing two
watches
right that's cool so does this look like
a watch
i don't know because that's cool um so
on
on my right hand i have a an old garmin
gps watch a phoenix uh phoenix 3 heart
rate and on my left wrist i have
the whoop band so if you're if you're
watching this on youtube you haven't
heard
the ad reads the sponsored ad reads that
i do for woop
on the audio version of the podcast um
this whoop
this thing is a and again i'm saying
this is not a sponsored post at all like
i'm just
sharing what i do right the woop is
a wristband essentially fitness
tracker that connects with a mobile app
but it's it's it's not about gauging
your workouts per se it's much more
about
rest and recovery and sleep and so
by leaving it on all day it monitors
your heart rate and monitors your heart
rate variability your metabolic rate
it tracks your sleep and breaks down how
much time you spend in the various sleep
stages
and then it kind of crunches all of this
data and
delivers these metrics on how
rested you are how recovered you are how
much strain
you should undergo that day or shouldn't
and it also calculates the strain that
you put your body through every day so
basically
it's kind of a helpful tool in helping
you
calibrate your workouts so that you're
not over training or not
not under training right like how do you
kind of meet your strain goals every day
and make sure that your body is
properly recovering and when you're
training really hard
it's a great way of adjudicating
whether you've pushed too hard the day
before when you should like sort of
ease back and when you kind of have the
green light to
push harder than you have in past days
so i haven't taken this thing off since
i got it
maybe i don't know six months ago or
something like that maybe i've had it
really
remember like yeah i love it it's
waterproof um
and it's amazing like i swam this
morning you don't have to
push any buttons or there's no interface
or anything like that and i swam and
then
i refresh my app and it's like oh you
swam this far for this long
really knows your heart rate and it has
a little optic sensor on the the back of
it
that um is how it's calibrating the data
this is pretty cool jealous yeah
but then in terms of working out
i prefer i prefer a proper gps watch
in terms of the data that i want to look
at for distance
and pace um yeah for a couple reasons
first of all uh it has an interface so
you can see it when you're like if i'm
out running i want to know what my heart
rate is right so i can look at my watch
and know what that is at any given
moment
it also will um
via bluetooth connect with a heart rate
monitor strap around the chest which i
think is much more preferential than
these
optic sensors that you see on the the
back sides of these gps watches that are
calibrating your heart rate
from your wrists which i have found at
least to date i think the sciences and
the technologies
always iterating and getting better and
better better but i found that that
gauging your heart rate off your a chest
strap is much more accurate and stable
better than your arm as well right yeah
yeah yeah much much more so
so i highly suggest getting a chest
strap for your heart rate
in terms of what kind of gps watch to
get like i said this this is a garmin
that i'm wearing
right now and it's super old like
there's been many iterations on this
since i bought it but i still
love it it works perfectly fine and
i don't know that it matters that much
which watch you have i tend to wear this
one kind of because
it's like nice and heavy and metal and
it just feels like a real
regular watch that you can wear out into
the world kind of like yours years yeah
some years it's just a different
variation of mine
right um and uh mine just has a dive
component
and it works perfectly fine the the sort
of user interface
in terms of um getting the screens to do
what you want them to do is a little bit
kind of clunky i would say and that's
where uh
a competitor watch this is this is the
koros
this is the brain this is the coros
vertex in cortex
and it's very similar to the garmin um
but the advantages of this watch which i
should disclose they sent to me for free
this is not a sponsored
thing at all i'm not getting paid to say
this but they did send me a free watch
and i really like this watch too because
the user interface is much more
intuitive
it's much more easy to navigate through
the different screens and to get to the
data that you want
its interface with its mobile app is
incredibly seamless it uploads to strava
without any hassles whatsoever and it
has unbelievable battery life
so this thing you can wear for like
weeks without charging it whereas the
garmin you have to charge much more
frequently so i like them both for
different reasons
the garmin feels more like a knock
around wear everyday watch but
this one i also found is
has some wonkiness in in the swim
metrics that the garmin doesn't have but
the garmin isn't always super accurate
with swimming on ocean ocean swims the
garment
fades in and out of gps connectivity
yeah yeah i would agree with that
and these are things that are like
software pushes that are always
improving
yeah um but i like them both and the
koros is like a small little startup
and they're making waves in the space
and i think what they're doing is super
cool so
you can check them out can you swim in a
chest um
heart rate monitor you can i don't i
don't worry about that i mean since i've
been swimming my whole life i'm pretty
into it i can intuitively gauge my my
sort of perceived effort
um a lot of people do a lot of
triathletes wear the strap when they're
swimming so it's okay it doesn't doesn't
impact
you you definitely need a chest drop
that would be one thing i would suggest
yeah yeah i need one and then just get
really connected
with um with your heart rate and
i don't need it all the time now because
i've been using one for so many years
that i just know like i'm like i
i i know how i feel and i know basically
where my heart rate is all the time
without looking
but that only comes through experience
all right so there's that
here's something i bet you've never
heard of or seen before and these are
um this is a pair of goggles and they're
made by a company called
form have you heard of these no these
are cool and also these were sent to me
for free as well are they night vision
goggles they are they look kind of like
that too they like
swim goggles they look like uh some kind
of futuristic
swim goggle they've got this little
doodad on
on once one side of it a little computer
thing
and basically what they do is it's like
a it's like an ar device when you put
them on
and turn it on you'll see a little
digital readout in your visual field
yeah and when you hit start it's
basically a gps watch for swimming
it's google glasses for swimming
basically yeah and when you're swimming
it will you you input like the the size
of the pool 50 meters 25 meters or
whatever
and there's a running clock and you can
you can kind of
adjust customize the data fields but
basically it gives you
a running time and also
a tally on your distance and it knows
when
you are doing an interval set like it'll
say
like if i'm doing a set of 10 100s it
will when i finish the 100 it'll flash
like the time
that i did that 100 yards in and then
it'll do a running clock of like how
long i've rested before i push off again
so it's essentially like using
a pace clock but the pace clock is just
in your visual field while you're
swimming
and when these were sent to me i thought
there's no way these things are going to
work like it's just not going to be that
good
but i was really amazed how well they
were
you're seeing all that yeah you see you
see it like it appears
like in like uh like an alternate you
know
ar like a vr kind of experience you're
the terminator you're wearing these
and they work really well and i'm blind
like without my glasses i was like i'm
not even gonna be able to read these
numbers but i could see them totally
fine
and so this has been a a really fun
doodad gadget
that i've been playing around i would
totally buy them if it had like
you know like um the parking
like you can get you get cars that
automated parking if you could do an
automated flip turn
i'd buy it tomorrow if it trains for you
and you can like does
it what if you lay in bed and you put
them on and it pretends like you're
swimming and then every time i
cross the room it flips me upside down
that would be crazy
all right one more thing these things
are
the jaybird vista earbuds jaybird is a
podcast sponsor
and i'm sponsored by them personally as
well so
they're not they didn't sponsor me
talking about this right now but they
are a partner of mine and i love
business i love this product so do you
ever wear earbuds i don't i don't i
don't listen to it which is fine
that's good you know i think it's
important to go out in nature and just
experience nature for what it is
if you are going to listen to podcasts
or audiobooks or music
when you're training though i i highly
suggest these be
your choice um and i are they obviously
obviously i'm biased because i work with
this program but i sought them out
because i love them
they're not you can't swim like go
diving in them or anything like that but
they're incredibly um they're waterproof
to the extent that you could sweat on
them
and you could jump in a pool or whatever
and they would be fine i've dropped
these in the pool and they
they they're perfectly fine wow and no
matter how much i sweat they stay in my
ear
they never fall out they're super easy
to use and
uh and i love them so you know again
just another like
cool fun they come in this this pack
that charges the
that charges them charging pack and the
battery life's excellent and they're
incredibly durable
do you have to have your phone with you
when you're uh to have them work or do
you
download it onto your watch no no i
don't have an apple watch i don't know
what that would be like because i think
you can and this one has like i could
put i i could
i could really music on this thing i
don't even know about that yeah you're
the one who should be doing that maybe
possibly i mean they just they just
connect via bluetooth so
they connect to my phone via bluetooth
so you just bring your phone on your
runs yeah exactly
yeah all right final thing oh yes did
you see this yes that's mathis work
right
right so um if you're listening and
you're not watching on youtube i'm
holding up a t-shirt that i
shared on instagram the other day and
it's a
yes it's a it's a it's a
graphic illustration of me i guess
loosely based on me i suppose
um that mathis
had made for father's day um i thought
we were all getting
uh t-shirts so her friend sterling
is the artist who's like this 15 year
old kid and he's the one who came up
with the design
but mathis kind of produced the project
and uh
and i posted it i mean it's like i can't
wear this i can't i can't go into the
world you can't wear your nose
yeah like i can't wear yours it's like
preposterous
shirt roger federer wears an rf hat
does he yeah he does i feel like when
you reach a certain level you can get
away with it yes
like i can't imagine like you're not
there yet in the world
but i posted on instagram mathis is like
asking who wants merch
and like a lot of people seem like they
were into it so
i don't know you know if you it's great
leave a comment on
on youtube below if you if you would be
interested in this and maybe we can do a
limited run and make them available on
that on the board i would love that i'd
wear one
yeah i'd love to be the kind of guy that
could wear that there's mushrooms
growing out of my shoulders someone
invited you to take mushrooms but
i think that's against the sober thing i
think it is wouldn't you agree
unless they're four sigmatic mushrooms
a different kind of mushroom well no but
there's this whole idea of psychedelics
to cure addiction
yeah i know you don't buy into that no i
don't i i'm not
i'm not i mean this is we could do a
whole podcast on that i should probably
do that yeah i mean and i've spoken
about this on in the past on the podcast
like i'm a product of 12 step
i believe in alcoholics anonymous you
know i
i got sober that way i stay sober that
way and i've seen
countless lives transformed as a result
of working 12-step
um it's it's it's just it's a it's a
it's a miraculous and beautiful program
that uh is unlike anything i've ever
experienced
um but that's not to say that
i also i know plenty of people who've
gotten sober in in other ways
and i've never i've never done
psychedelics
so for me to speak to that with any
authority
i think would be foolish and i know that
there's
i'm sure you have yeah but just like for
my training not with any intelligence
whatsoever
right before you go out for your swim
run just a handful of uh
a handful of mushrooms yes when i was in
treatment there was a guy
who uh in my rehab who
uh he had like long white hair and he
said that
he used to for like a decade he
he was in the restaurant business and he
owned a restaurant uh he would wake up
in the morning
and he would he would take lsd and he'd
go on a 10-mile run
he said he did that every day that's
crazy
i could barely i could barely sit up
when i was on lsd
i was lying down most of the time but i
know that there's a lot of interesting
science happening right now specifically
at
johns hopkins around the use of
psychedelics and depression
ptsd exactly exactly and i think that's
a good thing yeah that's a good thing
um and ayahuasca obviously a big one um
win of the week
i got a win of the week i dug one up go
for it
um my win of the week is congratulations
to kai lenny
for his five nominations in the big wave
awards
the wsl just announced on july 20th if
you don't know about
kai he is a true innovator in surfing
he's one of the best if not the best big
wave rider alive
he is crossed the molokai channel riding
wind bumps on his foil
um he's a master windsurfer uh and
even this year when uh kovet broke out
he was in tahiti
competing competing on the qualifying
tour now remember this is a guy who wins
big wave contests but he was competing
on the qualifying tour
so that he could be on the wsl
championship tour as well to be one of
the rare writers that competes in in
both
formats at the same time often it's
surfers choose one or the other um and
he's kind of the heir apparent to laird
hamilton at jaws kind of innovating with
foils innovating with
a windsurfer who also is a resident
basically lives right right at jaws
um and he got nominated for five uh
nominations three of their five biggest
waves of the year
um nominations in the category he rode
three of them so he's got three of those
um one of those was at jaws two of them
were nazare
he's also nominated for best overall
performer and for wave of the year
from jaws nazare is that ridiculous wave
in portugal it's the mountain of the
wave
like where you always see there's that
building that's in the foreground every
time
kind of that rocky kind of uh bluff
that's like right there
and uh yeah that's the one the hundred
foot waves right where people ride and
he
he got a crazy ride there and he said he
rode
he got that wave um everyone took the
videos everyone took the pictures and
then he went out and served for three
more hours there
that's what he told me because i was
interviewing him for a different story
that's like yeah david goggins when he
when he parachuted into the iron man
world championship swimsuit
did the race finished it and then went
and worked out later that day
did you know that yes yes i remember i
remember that story yeah yeah he told me
that story
and that story of that is that he
parachuted in he was doing that with
um another navy seal who
was who they both parachuted in together
swam in they did the thing it was all
you know it was basically the tv kind of
it was going to be one of their
their uh things they ran and he was
behind the other seal
the entire race until the because he had
problems i think
he fell behind in the swim and then he
had issues at the beginning of the run
where he couldn't like
get his rhythm and he was walking a lot
of it then he found his rhythm and
started hammering as he does
and then he caught the guy like right at
the end and the guy looked at him and
goes
[ __ ] goblins man
i think that's exactly what i said to
him when we started our podcast
that's how i opened our podcast yeah
yeah yeah and they finished together
david couldn't beat it but yeah they
finished together that's classic
yeah yeah yeah good deal um i have a
quick win of the week
and that is shining a spotlight on
valerie allman
i tweeted this the other day valerie is
a discus athlete and she just broke the
american record in discus
and i shared this video uh we'll link it
up in the show notes
of her uh of her breaking the record and
her
swinging the discus did you see this no
it's hypnotizing
it's like ballet and performance art
in extraordinary athleticism check that
out
i'm having adam watch this right i'm
watching discus it's i like washed it
like 10 times in a row i couldn't stop
watching it
wow it's so extraordinary and she's a
wazelle athlete
wazelle is the kind of women first
apparel uh brand that works with
uh athletes like lauren fleschmann who's
been on the podcast before a really cool
company
amazing she's like a whirling dervish i
know it's not about gold
so yeah beautiful congratulations of
elite athletes is always incredible like
like the footwork of some of these
athletes is just
next level i think that she you know i
don't know because i haven't spent
a bunch of time looking into her
background but i think she has a
background in dance or ballet okay which
is not surprising that's probably why i
can't throw the discus that well no
that's the reason that's what it comes
down it's only because of your lack of
dance background yeah and my bad foot
i'm not sure if i brought that up yet
but
okay all right so that's it let's take a
quick break and we'll be back with
questions from the audience all right
all right and we're back let's do some
listener questions what do you got adam
let's do it we got
two that were emailed one is from an
anonymous
woman and let's get into it
she wanted to keep her name out of it i
live with an angry manic alcoholic and
things seem to be getting worse
or perhaps it's that my tolerance and
patience levels have diminished
but it's gotten to the point where not
only am i affected by this
but also my family every day is like
walking on eggshells
never knowing when the next bomb is
going to go off but you know it will
he's also had episodes of threatening
suicide and not coming out of the room
for days when i suggest therapy he
pooh-poohs it
and says he will change with diet and
exercise and will go super extreme and
fast for days
or even for a week sometimes he'll
continue to drink beer while he's
fasting but not always
he's told me i'm useless asked if i'm
[ __ ]
etc i know that this is a dis-ease
and i'm trying to stick by him but it's
getting more and more difficult
i certainly do not find it acceptable to
treat me and my sisters in an unloving
way
we have been together for over 20 years
and i've never believed in giving up
but i don't want to live the rest of my
life with this negative energy how can i
help him and myself
uh thank you for the question it's a
super important
um topic subject matter my heart goes
out to you
it's an incredibly difficult situation
and knowing how to navigate it
uh is is
one of the most fraught and emotionally
challenging things i can possibly
imagine
so first of all i'm empathetic to your
situation you're in a very difficult
spot
and i can't tell you what you should or
should not do
you have to make those decisions for
yourself
but perhaps i can give you a couple
light posts here
and one is first and foremost you have
to
take care of yourself you've got to
figure out how to
you know you have to figure out um
how to protect yourself and insulate
yourself against
the unhealthy his unhealthy behaviors
and it's not indulgent
for you to do so you shouldn't feel
guilty for doing that
and in fact it's of service to him for
you to do so
the way that you can do that is to seek
out al-anon
i think that you would find great solace
in that program
to participate in a community of people
who have
experience going through exactly what
you're going through right now
and understand that there are only so
many things that you can control here
you can control your behavior you can
control your response
to your spouse but what you can't
control
is him or his behavior so to the extent
that you're trying to get him to change
you're in a situation in which that's
very unlikely to occur hopefully he will
reach a point
in his addiction where he will
develop the willingness to try to get
better but
from what you've written here it doesn't
sound like he's in that place right now
he is succumbing to the great obsession
of every alcoholic which is
the effort to try to control your
drinking and he's going through the
machinations and the experimentation
to convince himself that he can do that
whether it's fasting or exercise
his pursuits in those regards are all in
extremis so it's clear that there are
manifestations of the underlying
disease that he has which is addiction
and
your ability to manage or control that
will
result in a lot of unhappiness on your
part so
i think your focus needs to be placed on
yourself
making sure that you're safe and healthy
nobody
should have to submit themselves to that
kind of abuse
whether it's emotional or physical i
can't tell you whether you need to end
the relationship or not
you need to make that decision for
yourself but i can tell you
that you are valuable
in this world and nobody should be
talked to
in that regard so take the steps that
you need to take
to protect yourself and your family
members who are on the receiving end
of this kind of abuse there are
resources available to you
even in the age of covid and again
that's where i think your priority needs
to be in terms of how you communicate
with him
and perhaps be of service to him
you can set healthy boundaries around
what is and is
is not acceptable you can tell him look
if you speak to me that way
again i'm going to leave or whatever it
is whatever
esteemable act you take on behalf of
yourself to create that boundary
i think is important and letting him
know where that boundary exists
so that if he disobeys it
or transgresses it then there will be
a ramification or a repercussion whether
that means you leave him or not
again you have to figure out that for
yourself
but i think establishing those
boundaries is the first step
in terms of letting him know that his
behavior is not okay
and i think the more specific and con
concrete you can be
around that the better it is for
yourself
and for him you can make suggestions hey
listen i think you should go to
treatment
you should go to detox you should check
out a.a you can make those suggestions
but it's important
that you remain divorced from
expectations as to whether he will avail
himself of that advice
and also any attachment that you have to
outcomes
if you are if if you have an expectation
that he's going to get sober or he's
going to do it you're going to what you
advise him to do then i think you're
setting yourself up for
um for a lot of uh
emotional woe so it's fraught it's very
difficult
especially with loved ones because you
can see
the person beneath the disease and you
are able to hold out hold space for that
individual
but sometimes they're just unable to see
it for themselves and in truth
you can't get an alcoholic sober the
alcoholic gets sober when the alcoholic
develops the willingness
to take the actions and the steps
required to get sober
and that's a very personal journey so as
harsh as it may sound
this person might have to suffer
greater repercussions might have to
be in more pain than he is in right now
in order to hit that bottom
and have that reconciliation for himself
you can make yourself available
for him if and when he reaches that
point but you need to protect yourself
emotionally
and not make yourself available for all
of the abuse
and the unhealthy behavior that he is
manifesting at the moment yeah
um heavy the only thing i can add is
you you said safe making sure you're
safe and i can tell you
from my previous reporting and things
that i've learned
is that um physical abuse
doesn't necessarily have to build up
from like a a push or a slap
you could get you could be in danger
already and i don't want to um
make you hysterical or anything like
that but but
this kind of emotional abuse you're
already on a path
um that you don't want to be on and so i
would instead
i don't know if allernon has uh domestic
i'm sure they do have like domestic
abuse
counseling recommendations but i would
also i'd look into some domestic abuse
hotlines
that you can yeah maybe we could put
some resources up in the show yeah
and i would call someone asap and i'm
not suggesting
anything other than calling and just
make your own decisions on how you want
to proceed but
you're already in a place that leads to
that could lead to a dangerous situation
for yourself
i think i would add that it's not
i ca i can't diagnose another person as
an alcoholic you know this anonymous
person is saying her husband is an
alcoholic she's diagnosing him is that
maybe he perhaps
admits it to her i don't know
the the the diagnosis of alcoholism
is is something that only the alcoholic
can can diagnose for themselves
but if this person is an alcoholic and
it would appear that he is
these things don't tend to just get
better they get worse
the best case situation is they stay the
same
but generally they degrade
and devolve and with that
comes a notching up of the abuse
and the unhealthy behaviors that circle
around that
so short of an intervention or
this person developing the willingness
to get better for himself
this is going to continue to progress
and again
that just means that it's all the more
important that you take care of yourself
100 all right um
let's go to jake in kansas city this is
another emailed
uh question you've talked in the past
about people getting addicted to
self-help
that we mistakenly search for the next
hack the next optimization strategy
i felt this way in my own experience to
self-improvement
i tend to consume all that's out there
and while i live out some of it
i find myself being more concerned with
reading or listening to the next thing
whatever that may be so how do i go
about choosing the top three to five
things i find most valuable
and just walking that path how do you
stay committed to learning and growing
while also remaining steadfast to a
short list of pursuits that you're 100
committed to
how do we avoid consuming self-help as
an end in itself
instead of just a means to a greater end
thanks
that's a great question it goes back to
analysis paralysis
what we were talking about before
whether it's the gear or
self-help literature these are just
devices to distract you and prevent you
from actually
moving forward i've got nothing against
self-help literature it helps lots of
people
you know i think it's good that it
exists in the world but i've also become
a little bit cynical about it as a
podcaster i'm now on these
lists with all the publishing houses so
i get all the galleys of all the
nonfiction books in the mail
before they come out so every week i get
like
10 self-help books in the in the mail
yes and every author wants to come on
the podcast and
after receiving like 100 of these over
the year you're like
how much self-help literature do we need
there can't be that many secrets to
getting better
and then i think about david goggins and
i'm like how many self-help books did
that guy read
you know how many he read zero he got
off his ass
and he got to work yeah right so
self-help is fine
you know if you if you need some
guidance if you lack
mentorship or education in your life
such that these are helpful to you
i think that's great but when you start
to use them as a shield to insulate you
from taking any actions
obviously they're becoming an impediment
they're the very thing that is
preventing you from helping yourself
it's interesting the irony in that right
yeah it's interesting like this
this fact that neuroscience has become
so popularized
it kind of makes us like attuned to
optimization and in this tech world
where everything's supposed to optimize
like there's a whole
like tim ferriss's kind of position and
how to optimize like the work
week or how to do this or that um
it's uh it's interesting i think peop
there are people out there there's a
whole segment of population that are
interested in how to be
optimal but then the pursuit of that
but when you look at the most optimal
people in the world they're not the
people
that are focused on optimization
necessarily
so it is a weird kind of paradox i
suppose
um and i would say to jake listen
like he's like how do i go about
choosing the top three to five three
things i find most valuable and just
walking the path how about one thing
you know i can't tell you what your
values are but you know if you
can get clear on what your values are
and
establish something that you want to
manifest in your life
let's begin that process i think the
analysis paralysis comes in
in the plotting and the map making and
what is the trajectory and how am i
going to get there and there's so much
mental masturbation
that goes into that at the behest of
taking that first step
so again i think it goes
back to simplifying this process
we want to over complicate it and think
that we have to
lay on top of our goals some crazy
lattice work
right and i think that those can become
handicaps as much as tools it's
interesting i i think about the
hubermann thing talking about like how
habits first and then thought
and uh perceptions and everything follow
right behavior
behavior behavior first and then
everything else follows
um and the construction of habits it
sounds like
maybe he's the type of guy that gets
bored from doing the same thing over and
over again
and there is a certain boredom in
creating a habit that becomes like a
daily ritual
uh but you got to stick with something
about cr like creating habits for
yourself maybe every morning coming up
with a morning practice whether it's a
meditation or a yoga
um and then a meditation or something
that you commit to doing every day
something one thing that you commit to
doing every day
and then see see what that gets you as
opposed to whatever you got out of a
self-help book maybe there's some habits
that you can take that you can build
your days around
that you can lock in you know i think
that that's
good advice i would say and we talked
about this last time i think
that it's important to understand that
when you're consuming a self-help book
that that's not the accomplishment the
accomplishment
is in applying that wisdom to your life
right and so
the first step is understanding that
just because you read a book doesn't
mean that you did anything and i think
what happens is you read these books
and you feel like you're accomplishing
something or
growing in your life simply in the
consuming
of that book but that in and of itself
will it's like in 12 step they say um
half measures will avail you nothing
right so like reading
reading a book it's good you've consumed
this this piece of knowledge but unless
you figure out how to
apply it in some fungible tangible way
in your life
it will avail you nothing right so it's
disabusing you of that notion that
you've done something just because
you've read a book and it's
reconfiguring your perspective to focus
more on actions
you know to bring it back to huberman
behavior like lead with the behavior so
we're sitting here
having a podcast episode 500 and
whatever
i didn't start the podcast because i
read a self-help book
and tried to figure out what my values
were and created some
road map to where i would be seven years
later
i just thought this will be cool and i
turned on a mic i had it was a behavior
it was an action like
hey this might be fun and i was like
that was cool let's do it again
right it wasn't like a whiteboard
no situation no you know and i think
that's the problem with our
optimization obsessed culture is that we
think we have to have all of these
things
figured out before we begin and in truth
in my own personal experience
it's in the doing that the path is
revealed
yeah you never really know what the end
product is going to be
and um we don't even necessarily know
what
optimal is while we're experiencing it
right
it's all it's all kind of through
analysis later well there's also a
binary nature to that very conversation
around
optimization anyway you know i i i lean
more
towards the ethereal unknowing of it all
yeah right that you can remember there's
a spirituality to all of this as well
that i think gets lost in the
conversation around
optimization which is you know
this assumption that we can drill
everything down to ones and zeros
and create an equation for success and i
just don't think it works that way
that doesn't mean that we can't learn
and improve by virtue
of these tools but i think there's a
bigger
dance at play and broadening your
perspective and understanding that
i think at least it's been helpful to me
we've talked about that before i mean
just recognizing your speck of
consciousness in this great sea
is liberating in a way because it means
that
um there's so much more going on that
you can possibly be aware of and if you
just
handle your stuff in a systemic way
systematic way on a day-to-day basis um
is going to get you to a good place you
just don't know where that good place is
necessarily which is also a beautiful
thing
just think about this self-esteem comes
from
esteemable axe like that's a truth
right why is that the case can that be
defined in some kind of
binary optimization vernacular
like i think it's a spiritual principle
that we are the sum total of our actions
and if we do a steamboat
more than that we're more than the sum
total of our actions
but i think that that you know having a
just being able to broaden your aperture
a little bit
and understand that if you if you are
um if you are clear
in your intentions and you are full of
heart
pure of heart that when you whatever
path that you pursue
and i talked about this in my book like
the i believe that the universe will
conspire to support you if you've done
the inside work if you are
coming from a place of love and
compassion and gratitude
that the world will greet you in kind
and
that has nothing to do with you know
neuroscience necessarily
you disagree i i agree to a point
i think that uh chaos theory exists
and sometimes chaos descent on your head
well also
luck plays a huge part yeah yeah yeah so
i don't think it's always
it can always be that way but some but i
i can say that if you tend to greet
your experiences
i do think it comes down to how you deal
with the hand you're dealt
so sometimes you're dealt a really
shitty hand
and it's really hard to stay open and
positive about it um
but that doesn't mean that the person
who does stay open and positive about it
isn't going to have more success than
the one that doesn't
so i i think it's i think it's complex
but i do believe
you're right a lot of the time i also
believe that chaos
you know hurricanes hurricanes brew yeah
yeah and and that does happen point
taken yeah all right let's move on
moving on
let's listen to some voicemails hey i am
hey rich
uh this is jackson from middle of
nowhere wyoming
uh i deliver coronavirus
tests across the state and i love
listening to you guys when i'm on the
road
uh my question for you today is
as a 25 year old along with
plant-based eating what are some other
habits
things i can do in my life now that i
will appreciate
in the next 10 years thanks guys
that's such an awesome question i know
right i'm just
all i can think about is like what was i
doing when i was 25 i was such a
knucklehead i certainly wasn't like
trying to better myself by leaving
voicemails for podcasters you know or
delivering kinder eyes
exactly epidemic yeah god
big respect jackson huge respect very
cool
um well yeah plant-based diet that's
good yeah that's a good start
um i you know look there's no
behind the velvet rope here you know i
think the habits that you form at your
age at age 25
are things that you want to kind of um
uh
you know establish in your life that
then cr then
create their own momentum so that when
you're 40
50 and 53 they become second nature and
wrote
i know personally because i'm at my age
i have a lot of friends
who are now starting to deal with a lot
of health stuff that
they never really had to think about but
they never formed
proper healthy habits early on and now
they're confronted with having to
undo all of their unhealthy habits and
create new ones
which is much harder than just creating
a healthy habit when you're young
right that becomes second nature and
just part of who you are
part of your lifestyle as opposed to
something that
you know you feel like you have to focus
on it's just it doesn't even require any
brain bandwidth because it's
fundamentally who you are
i think at the top of that list i put
some form of exercise or movement
preferably something that you enjoy
because then it becomes second nature
and part of your lifestyle it almost
doesn't matter what it is as long as
it's
something that gets you outdoors
breathing fresh air gets your heart rate
up a little bit
and is something you can do consistently
throughout the week
i think that's super important
plant-based eating he's already got the
diet part down
i think developing a meditation and
mindfulness practice
a 25 i mean what a gift if you could
really
figure that out and nail that down at
your age the benefits that you'll see in
your life will be tremendous
and i think also developing a habit of
reading
not to go back to the guy who reads too
many self-help books but
you should always be reading books every
single interesting person that i've ever
met in my life is an avid reader
yes so if you can make reading a go-to
habit
it doesn't even matter to me what you
read it doesn't really matter as long as
you're reading all the time
i think that will make you uh stand
heads and shoulders above
your peers and just make you not only an
interesting person but a person who is
interested in the world well that's what
makes
those who are the most interesting
people right the ones that are still
like
trying to figure it out of course um
yeah i totally agree with you
i think um one thing that helped me when
i was younger
kind of build good habits just in
general
was starting a yoga practice um morning
yoga practice
uh i started by just doing nine sun
salutations
every morning before i did anything else
and uh just that alone
kind of got me to the point where i
could
like try to become a writer basically
like to like was that right
discipline i never considered myself a
disciplined person until i started doing
that
wow it taught me discipline so creating
some sort of morning ritual for yourself
doesn't have to be that
you can go run and but i think some sort
of meditation aspect some sort of like
metaphysical like spiritual aspect to
your day
does help you kind of stay grounded stay
humble
um and and stay ready yeah so what is
your connection to source
what does your higher power look like
yeah and how does that
infuse your life and set you on a
trajectory to
to bring meaning and purpose into your
life
um the other aspect of this that i would
mention is
is finding a way to be of service but
this is a guy who's delivering
coronavirus tests across the state like
he's doing he's providing a service but
i think when you approach your life from
a
service perspective from a perspective
of how can i contribute how can i give
how can i
provide as opposed to what am i getting
out of this for myself
that will not only make you a happier
person it will make you a more
productive person
a more contented person and just a
better individual
i think and somebody who other people
want to be around
also i'll add one more thing to the list
i don't want to overload you jackson but
travel internationally uh um
and not just to like nice places but to
places that might be
fraught to places that might be
challenging
uh make yourself uh put yourself
where you're one of the only foreigners
on the ground
and and just go explore that's the henry
henry rollins philosophy of life
that's right yeah pack a bag and go to
some weird corner of the planet
go to papua new guinea or somewhere like
that i think that's
yeah that's really good advice yeah and
i think also
you know to avoid overwhelming you just
break these things down into tiny little
chunks you know and don't beat yourself
up for not doing it perfectly every
single day
exactly um and i'll cap it off by just
saying it sounds like you're
you're in a car or truck for a lot of
hours during the day
it's where you listen to the podcast
thank you for doing that but
to the extent that you you know have all
this time in the car
like what else are you listening to like
don't just turn the radio on and
let it tell you what it wants to tell
you be mindful about
how you're programming your audio
throughout the day when you're spending
all that time
in a vehicle whether it's audiobooks or
other podcasts and the like
yeah make sure you get your qnon feed
kidding kidding yeah uh all right
let's go to rich no no that's you
let's go to adam in alberta canada hey
rich and adam my name is actually adam
too
i'm i in fact my name is adam burka
and i live in alberta canada i've been a
long time listener of the podcast in
fact i've been listening since episode
one
way back when you were recording in
hawaii which means i've literally
listened to you talk for
thousands of hours as i listen to 99 of
your podcast the question i have which
you do have my
permission to play on the podcast is
this
the topic of education has come up
frequently in your podcast and i happen
to be a teacher in a public school
in fact i'm a school administrator in
canada i often think about how somebody
can influence the world in a positive
way and how educators are positioned in
a highly influential role
while there are an increasing number of
mainstream education
alternatives for students which i think
are wonderful i still believe that
public education remains an important
avenue for a significant percentage of
the population
whenever health related guests are on
your show you ask them if they were to
wake up in a parallel universe as the
surgeon general
what health changes they would make to
this edu or to the system
so i'm going to ask you the same
question if you were to wake up in the
education world equivalent of surgeon
general
what changes would you make to the
education system as a whole
so that one could positively influence
children who i believe who i believe to
be
our most valuable resource and whom the
future of our planet relies on
keep up the great work guys that's an
amazing question
i like how well thought out it is too
yeah
um well he's a teacher yeah i know right
thanks adam um and thank you for
listening to the podcast for so long i
really appreciate that
i will say this that surgeon general
question that i
ask to doctors when they come on the
podcast
those people are trained in their
specific discipline
so should they become surgeon general
they actually have some level of
expertise so now i'm being asked to be
education czar you're not an educator
but yet you're an education podcast
right but i i would not consider myself
a teacher nor
an expert in education right in general
so my answer will be couched in that
caveat
yes um that said and i've touched on
this before
um i think that that uh
our educational system is a legacy of a
bygone era
it was developed in victorian times to
develop
good factory workers to be productive
in an increasingly industrialized
society
the world has changed and i think we
need to take a hard long
look at what we're teaching and why
we're teaching kids
what we're teaching them there's plenty
in the current curriculum that i think
should remain i'm not
for just overhauling it and being
completely radical and revolutionary
about it
but i do think we need to resort to
first principles
and really try to understand how much
our culture has changed
and how that impacts what we're teaching
children
and more importantly how we're teaching
them
i think that uh with technology and i've
said this before many times
everybody's got a super computer in
their in their in their pocket
that will answer any question that they
ever want to ask it
so this rote memorization kind of
default methodology
of teaching needs to be
called into question and i think we need
to shift away
from the memorization strategy
that is predominated and monopolized our
our education system for for too long
and focus on
how do we create amazing adaptable human
beings
who will be lifelong learners who are
interested in learning and interested in
the world
and i think that needs to start with
focusing on developing the esteem
of the students and then orienting
curriculum
around where they sit and what they're
interested in and expanding from there
we need to develop young people
who know how to work in teams who
understand leadership
who understand and appreciate listening
who know how to collaborate
who know how to work alongside each
other
on a project basis methodology of
learning as opposed to
the singular individualistic approach of
reading a textbook and regurgitation
that would be a start away from
memorization towards
analysis of the material that is
available to you yeah and i i think in
terms of being surgeon general like what
are the changes that i would make well i
would certainly
reallocate budgets such that public
education is
adequately and properly funded i think
it's woefully underfunded right now
and i think the funding is not directed
in
the best directions we have in the
united states
teachers that have to do gofundmes to
raise money so that they have equipment
to teach it's
ludicrous right every kid should have a
laptop or an ipad or some form of device
we you know have this opportunity
because of covid
to learn more about how digital learning
can
inform our educational procedures and
processes
and i know there's a lot of smart people
that are looking at this and that are
studying this
um you know the fact that that kids are
now learning from home
how does that affect long term what
happens when we finally
you know get over the hump here and
return to
classroom learning how much should we
retain of what we've experienced now
versus how much do we go back to the way
that it was before and i think
this this forced moment right now
is instructive in that we should be
really trying to understand how kids
learn in a better way and
when we return apply what we've learned
to create a better classroom experience
for all
so and i say all of that like this is
all very off the cuff
like i feel like i feel bad adam because
i should
i feel like i should have mapped out my
response um
no but you i think you asked that but no
you get into it i think that
that uh you know young people going into
the world right now and into the
workforce
need to no longer are we in a situation
where somebody
joins a corporation and spends their
entire career there
right no longer are we in the situation
where a young person is even going to
have
the same career field
for maybe even a small percentage of
their professional life
right so with that understanding
how do we train young people to be
better equipped to handle the strange
vicissitudes of
a technologically oriented global
economy and i think adaptability comes
to mind as
one of the most important things spoken
like a competitive swimmer turned
entertainment lawyer turned podcaster
and when you graduated law school did
was
did you ever anticipate doing something
called a podcast well there was no
like when i was in law school there's no
internet exactly
so no but that's you're the proof of
that adaptive
uh you know adaptability is my point is
right it's like that
that but then i look back and i'm like
well all the things i did
were in education and making me better
at being able to do what i'm doing today
but i couldn't have known that right i
mean but you've said
you already couched that in there saying
you would keep a lot of that art
that keep a lot of what already exists
because clearly you got
a lot out of your education yeah but
there was a lot of wasted time
a lot of it forgotten due to blackout
drunks yeah that too
you know i think you hit the nail on the
head with the number one thing
would be put some more money in where
our mouth is
and and to me that that that place is
teachers salaries
number one um we need your salaries we
need to
get we need to attract talent to to the
pool
yeah and you're not gonna do that uh by
paying people peanuts and it's
absurd the level of we need a cultural
social shift in our perception of
educators
100 these people are rock stars and
heroes and we need to treat them as such
we were talking before the podcast
about how how this medium
has created rock stars out of scientists
in a way that is unprecedented we were
talking about andrew huberman and david
sinclair and
matthew walker these amazing scientists
who are doing you know phenomenal work
in terms of longevity and sleep and
you know neuroscience etc in the past
they would have written a book
maybe the book would have done well who
knows but now they can go on these
podcasts and talk for two or three hours
and people are like so
thirsty for their wisdom and the
response
to the podcast that i that i've had with
these people has been
unbelievably tremendous people revere
these people
and it makes me think well we should
have the same perspective
for secondary educators and primary
educators
what if we were able to you know shift
our perception of this professional
career path
and understand that you know these these
are people that we need to hoist up
and that we need to celebrate in a way
that we don't right now and
to attract the best talent
to enter into that we're talking about
you know not just the future minds of
america in the world but
literally the you know the future of the
planet right when we're in this
existential crisis of
whether or not humanity is going to you
know survive
right the very real threats that we face
so yeah so we can't be paying people 40
grand a year
no to do it so uh yeah you got it i mean
that's the best way to uplift them is
pay them properly
yeah and uh yeah i love it
beautifully well said rich
all right let's go to jeremy in st
michael minnesota
hey rich hey adam uh this is jeremy from
from st michael minnesota and i
first of all just want to say thank you
to rich for the podcast it's been
really life-changing for me um i've been
listening
for about almost two years now i think
and uh
the the knowledge and insight it's given
me has been super helpful in everyday
life so
i appreciate it um uh the question i
have
is um for both of you i guess you're
both writers
and i was curious maybe more
from the sense of a personal story when
you feel like you know that
your story is worth writing
and putting out to the world and that it
might be received and
and kind of um
i don't i don't know exactly how to how
to ask the question but
you know i have a story i have a you
know i've
been through recovery i've been sober
for 15 years i've
you know done some things after recovery
that i feel you know would be of worth
for people to hear
and and maybe give them hope to
to do things in their own lives and i'm
just
i'm just curious how you come to the the
reality that this might be something
good to put down on paper and that your
story
might be received well in the world so
hope that makes sense
uh keep doing what you're doing and
thank you bye
all right jeremy listen
of course you should write
your story it sounds like you have an
amazing story i think
everybody should write their own story
and if you have
even the slightest inkling that you want
to share something
and that what you have to share could be
helpful to another human being
of course you should do that i can't
encourage you enough
to write what is inside of you that
clearly i can feel from
from your words is yearning to be
expressed
i sense some hesitancy and perhaps a
lack of of
um confidence
around doing this maybe a little bit of
fear
uh and and my sense is that that fear is
linked to
how what you would write will be
received and
what you have to do is let go of that
like just who cares how it's going to be
received detach those two yeah
these are two different things there's
the self-expression there's the telling
and then there's the reaction to it if
you get caught up into the reaction
you're dead out of the gate back to that
can't think about that at all
um you have to just basically
get into a place of pure expression
and allow it to you know emanate from
there
i think and you know i can only share my
own experience there's i'll tell two
quick stories
one is how the book finding ultra came
came to be in the first place because it
wasn't like i set out to write a book
i thought maybe in the back of my mind
one day i'll write a book but it wasn't
like i had
set this goal that i was going to write
write a memoir
right what happened was
um somebody who i didn't know
read about me in um a magazine article
reached out to me by email and
asked if i would be willing to talk to
him because he had just gotten out of
treatment
and was having a hard time and it was
somebody that i didn't know
but was somebody that was friends with
other friends of mine
so i struck up a friendship with this
guy and we would talk from time to time
on the phone
and i was trying to kind of help him
acclimate to
to being newly sober and
at one point he said hey you've got this
amazing story have you ever thought
about writing a book and i was like well
not really i mean kind of maybe but like
it wasn't a top of the mind thing
and he was like i know this book agent
you know
this book agent worked with dean
carnaz's
and it helped him with his books and you
know you should would you like me to
introduce you
like it was like that right and that led
from one that led to me being introduced
to this book agent and this book agent
being like well if you want to write a
proposal i'm happy to read it you know
this is a tough
thing you could thread the needle here i
wrote i worked really hard on a proposal
and she was still
very you know like grounded in her
you know tried to you know basically
prevent me from having high expectations
and we ended up selling the book and
that's how the book got made
and when i reflect on that story
what i take from it is that the good
thing whether you can qualify it is good
or not like the fact that i wrote a book
all started from basically being of
service to somebody else like taking
somebody's phone call and talking to
them about
recovery that was it i didn't have an
agenda
and that process led to something that i
could have never anticipated
that has changed my life in unbelievable
ways
and in the writing of that book i had
plenty of moments
of personal terror thinking like do i
want to be this open do i want to be
this vulnerable is this a good idea
and i would become paralyzed because i
was thinking about the audience
reception and the only way
that i could get through it was to
completely block that out
and just pretend that i was writing in a
private journal
and that no one would ever read it and
every moment every
you know once in a while i'd have this
flash of like the book being on a shelf
in a bookstore and i would panic
because i would get caught up in that
reception and that ultimately is the
enemy of creativity so
just pretend you're writing in your
personal journey and maybe you don't
share it with anybody and maybe you do
and maybe it impacts one person or maybe
it impacts a million people you don't
know
but the point of the exercise is to
engage with your
creative voice and to try to you know
basically
um be authentic to who you are
i love that so well said and it echoes
something that
our friend elizabeth gilbert has talked
about
um which is kind of in her book big
magic she gets into that a lot
is is um the point is the creative
output it's not
the you have to divorce yourself from
expectation you can't expect something
out of it
um especially when you're first starting
um
because you don't know about that it's
about you don't know where this one act
will take you
uh you know i've never written a memoir
like you but i wrote
my the way i got an agent was i wrote an
uh a fictional
novel kind of loosely based on my life
and i did put a lot of stuff in in there
that was very personal
and um ended up getting me an agent
which helped my
you know got me into into the publishing
houses so right
so uh that's how it started for me too
by doing that didn't sell the book
didn't didn't make a dollar
off of middle of somewhere it's still in
it's still somewhere
it's still in my computer though but you
know what i mean but i never you know
obviously i had ambitions for it but
yeah um but it led me somewhere else
and and so that's the point is is if you
wanted
if you're feeling the passion you're
feeling the urge to create you gotta
you gotta give it some energy right yeah
right so clearly
i could feel there's something inside of
him yearning to be expressed and that's
really
the only important thing awesome
cool cool all right one last one this is
the
personal uh more of a personal question
for you
this is henry from los angeles
california
from what i've gathered you rich and
julie
srimati have a relationship that is
pretty similar to me and my wife
and by that i mean you're both clearly
spiritual and empowered in your own ways
but you rich seem to be more practical
rational and grounded
whereas julie is the more esoteric
receptive intuitive one
in my experience that relationship
balance has been really beneficial for
personal growth
for me and my partner but my question is
about working together
when you collaborate on projects how do
you balance each other's energy
without getting dragged down by
differences in work styles and
priorities
what rules or guidelines whether they're
unspoken or formal
have you set up to bring out the best in
each other and not let disagreements
grind projects to a halt
that's a great question adam you can
play this question on the air
thank you that's a great question henry
thank you for that
uh this has been an evolving
you know journey for julie and i to
figure this out and definitely a tricky
equation
to solve but i think we've done a good
job and figured it out and i think the
key for me
has been um
not needing her
to do things the way that i would do
them and respecting that difference
right so julie and i are incredibly
different we have our own respective
projects but then we come together to
collaborate on
on things from time to time and
early on in that adventure i would say
you have you know it's like i
this is how you do these things you have
to do it like and she would not do that
you know like and i would get frustrated
and angry and i'm sure she was
angry with me because you know she has
her perspective on how you would do
project x and i'm not meeting that
expectation so
we had to go through it in order to
figure out a language around
communicating and also guide posts and
boundaries
about how to work together so we did he
have it right the way that did he
did he handicap it right in terms of
you're the rational grounded and she's
the esoteric kind of intuitive yeah
but i think i think that that what
what's missing in that
is that julie is incredibly smart and
competent and
she gets [ __ ] done like she's a doer so
it's not like she's all airy fairy and
up in the clouds and like can't
you know make any practical progress
like she
gets [ __ ] done and she knows how to get
[ __ ] done and she's better
at a lot of things that i am so a lot of
it has been
figuring out where she excels and where
my handicaps are and where i excel
and where there are areas that she
doesn't care about and then we try to
meet each other
so that she's doing the things that
she's best at and i'm filling in the
gaps where
you know she is you know less competent
in so
julie for example is very good at the
global picture
and i'm a very i get mired in the
details
so you need both of those right you need
a detail-oriented person and you need
somebody who's
thinking more broadly about what it is
that you're actually doing
and that functions when you understand
that those are your
roles julie's a much better team person
she's a leader she knows how to get a
lot of people around her who are excited
about what she's doing
and i'm a like a solo guy like i'm very
good when i'm just
by myself so those are different
those have you know positives and
negatives so it's where do those
where do all when you look at a certain
project like how are we going to fit
together
and let's allocate the tasks so that
we're focused on the things that we're
best at
and most interested in and i think when
you do that
and this doesn't happen overnight like
it this happened over time for us
then you can become like like
a superpower because you're meeting each
other like you're
you're filling in each other's gaps
right and then
the product of that collaboration tends
to be
um exponential rather than than
um just additive i suppose
but i think it has to do with
self-understanding and also
really understanding your partner and
then developing
really effective communication between
you guys
because these things especially when
you're working together emotions can run
hot
and things can get heated and things can
get misunderstood
and it's really critical that you have a
way of communicating in a balanced and
objective way
because otherwise these things can be
combustible and
they blow apart a lot of relationships
so
the communication has to be strong the
self-understanding and the understanding
of your partner has to be intact before
you even launch into one of these
projects but if you're if you have that
sorted out then i think you're in a good
position to collaborate together and
it's beautiful to do that
um i've had amazing creative
professional experiences working with my
wife but it's also important
that at the same time we have our own
respective things that we do
outside of our collaborations so they're
that we're not
sort of solely resting on you know our
co
our sort of co-collaborations for our
kind of you know um professional
well-being
well you just need to have those silos
that you go into on your own so you can
be your own whole human being outside of
raising kids and having a life and
having a romantic life and also having a
business
you got to have your own so it sounded
like communication
skills um a solid understanding of your
own strengths and weaknesses and
and shared understanding of both of your
collective strengths and weaknesses
together
right and how those fit right and then
making sure that
yes you collaboration can be awesome but
you also have to
have some room to do your own projects
too
which will feed the collaboration right
right the communication i can't i can't
overstate how important that is because
if you're in the heat of the moment and
you can't
figure out a way to get balanced and
give each other
objective feedback that isn't then
completely
emotionalized yeah you're going to be
doomed
so really what you should do is just get
a lot of ikea furniture
and both try to put it together and then
by the end
of confederations yeah yeah exactly
you'll
be divorced or
[Laughter]
uh that's great anything to add uh i
think that's
it that's what i would say for now good
rock thank you henry i think we did it
we're done
we took a one and a half hour podcast
and made it three hours i know
that's hard to do we were gonna try to
do this in an hour i don't know what
we're doing are we getting better at
this or worse i don't know
it depends who you ask yeah don't ask
chad wolfe
but listen you know it's a podcast you
can listen to half of it you can listen
half of it later you can abandon it
i don't know but i like what we did
today i did too man
thank you my friend we'll be back here
in two weeks uh you can follow adam on
all the socials at adam skolnik i'm at
rich roll if you want your
question answered on the show you can
leave us a voicemail at 424-235-4626
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button on youtube that notification
little bell
subscribe on apple podcast on spotify
uh check the show notes on the episode
page at richworld.com we'll link up
everything that we discussed here today
you can also submit your questions on
the facebook group
and uh i think that's it thank you for
taking this journey with adam and i
and we'll see you back here in a couple
days with another awesome episode any
closing thoughts
no it's just uh thanks for listening
it's your moment to be profound this is
it
um no i appreciate everybody who listens
and
cares about getting better and being
better it's uh it's really cool to be a
part of this journey
i really uh appreciate it don't take it
lightly and and i
thank you rich and for all who listen
thank you man appreciate it
yeah see you guys soon peace
[Music]
you